GOOD AFTERNOON I'M CALLING THE
JOINT INFORMATION HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE EDUCATION
COMMITTEES.
TO ORDER I KNOW SENATOR ALLEN IS
EXPECTED TO BE HERE BUT WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD BECAUSE WE ONLY
HAVE THIS ROOM TILL FOUR. AND I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE GET ALL THE
TOPICS COVERED.
I'D LIKE TO OPEN THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND THE PUBLIC TO WHAT I
EXPECT WILL BE A VERY.
INFORMATIVE.
HEARING.
IN ONE I JUSTICE CENTER MORE
ELECTED YOU WISH TO SHARE ANY
THOUGHTS BEFORE I CAN GO THROUGH
SOME OKAY. MEDICAID IF YOU DO.
SPEAK UP BY IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
CALIFORNIA ADOPTED A NEW LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA AND LAID
THE GROUNDWORK FOR A NEW SYSTEM
OF SCHOOL ACCOUNTABILITY. AND
CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT.
THAT'S SYSTEM WHICH IS BASED ON
USING MULTIPLE MEASURES INSTEAD
OF A SINGLE NUMERICAL NUMBER TO
MEASURE EFFECTIVENESS
CONSISTS OF THE FOLLOWING MAJOR
COMPONENTS.
THE REQUIREMENT OF THE LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES ADOPT AND
ANNUALLY REVISE THE LOCAL
CONTROL AND ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS
THE ACCOUNTS.
THE REQUIREMENT FOR COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION REVIEW AND
APPROVE SCHOOL DISTRICT L. CAPS.
NEW COMMON CORE ALIGNED
ASSESSMENTS INCLUDING THE S.
BACK WHICH IS ADMINISTERED IN
GRADES THREE THROUGH EIGHT AND
ELEVEN.
THE CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE OFTEN
CALLED C. C. E.. WHICH IS
CURRENTLY WORKING WITH NINE
PILOT TEST DISTRICTS
ONE OF WHICH WILL HEAR FROM
TODAY AND THAT'S A VERY
INTERESTING APPROACH. FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE.
THE ADOPTION OF A DASHBOARD TO
DISPLAY SCHOOL AN ALLEY A
PERFORMANCE.
ACROSS MULTIPLE MEASURES AND THE
USE OF THE DASHBOARD IN THE
FALL.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO IDENTIFY
TWO HUNDRED TWENTY EIGHT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE NEED OF
DIFFERENTIATED.
PERFORMANCE.
WE'RE NOW IN THE PROCESS OF
ADDING ANOTHER COMPONENT TO OUR
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM WHICH IS
THE STATE ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN
REQUIRED BY THE SL EVERY STUDENT
SUCCEEDS ACT OF COURSE THAT
BEING THE FEDERAL LAW.
AND FINALLY THE GOVERNOR HAS
PROPOSED ADDING TO OUR STATE
SYSTEM BY CREATING REGIONAL
SYSTEMS OR AMONG COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION. AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION LOCAL PLANNING AREAS
THE SOLE PURPOSE.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS HEARING
TODAY IS TO GET AN OVERVIEW ON
WHERE WE'VE BEEN AND WHERE WE
ARE AND WHERE WORLD WHERE WE ARE
GOING AND WHY THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT ME AS CHAIR OF THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE. IS WE GET
MANY BILLS YOU'RE SUGGESTING
THAT WE CREATE ACCOUNTABILITY
PLAN IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND YOU KNOW WE HAVE ONE IF IF
YOU'RE IN THE SERENE ABOUT A
EVEN LEGISLATORS.
IN THIS BUILDING.
DO NOT KNOW WHAT THIS PLANET SO
THE PURPOSE OF THIS HEARING IS
TO INFORM STAFF INFORMED
LEGISLATORS AND OF COURSE
BEYOND.
OF THIS EFFORT AND HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS TO THE SET SECURE YOUR
SUCCESS IN CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN.
AND THE FACT IS THIS IS BEING
WATCHED WE ARE THE MODEL FOR THE
NATION.
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING AT WHAT WE
ARE DOING WITH THEIR LCF HALF
AND BEYOND IN OUR ACCOUNTABILITY
SYSTEM TO TRY TO IT CLOSE THAT
ACHIEVEMENT BET GAP.
BECAUSE I.
I THINK ALL BUSINESS ROOM NO
THERE'S NOT ONE THING.
YOU CAN DO TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP IF THERE WAS A
FLIP YOU COULD SWITCH ARE THERE
SWITCHED FLIP WE WOULD HAVE
ALREADY DONE IT.
GAME WE TRIED MANY APPROACHES WE
DON'T HAVE YOU KNOW THE PERFECT
WAY TO CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
I ASSURE YOU AS WE SIT HERE
LOOKING AT THAT CLOCK.
IT'S WATAN PROBABLY FIFTH
PERIOD.
RIGHT IN MANY CLASSES ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND TEACHERS
ARE TRYING.
TO MOVE STUDENTS FORWARD AND IN
MANY CASES CLOSE THAT
ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND IT IS OUR
JOB TO SUPPORT THEM.
AND THIS NEW SYSTEM IS AN STF
AFFECTS NOT SACRAMENTO CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA ITS LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
WE TRIED.
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
MICROMANAGEMENT ON STEROIDS FOR
A LOT OF YEARS AND THE FACT OF
THE MATTER IS IT DID NOT WORK I
LIVED IT. IN THE CLASSROOM.
MY SELF ASA TODAY WE TURN THE
CORNER TRYING A NEW APPROACH
MORE ORGANIC ORGANIC APPROACH A
BOTTOM UP APPROACH. AND THAT'S
WHAT TODAY'S HEARING IT IS
ABOUT.
AND.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT THIS
INTERESTING I'M LEARNING A LOT
EVEN AS ONE OF THE CLASS OF A
LOT OF YOURS I DIDN'T ALL
UNDERSTAND THIS ACCOUNTABILITY.
APPROACH SO SO THIS IS A UNIQUE
NEW AND INTERESTING AND HERE WE
GO CALIFORNIA SO THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR BEING HERE TODAY. ALL.
GREAT OF ALL THREE.
GREAT SO AGAIN THANK YOU.
FOR BEING HERE.
NO CHILD LEFT BEHIND IS GONE
WE'VE LEFT THAT BEHIND RUN TO
SOME NEW IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT SO
HERE WE GO. BECAUSE FIRST WILL
BRING UP AN OVERVIEW OF THE
SYSTEM.
OF CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT
THAT'LL BE CARRICK ASHLEY.
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION OF PERFORMANCE
PLANNING AND TECHNOLOGY BRANCH.
COME ON UP CARE OF ALL CALL THE
NAMES OF THOSE OF YOU JUST COME
UP TO NEXT FEATURE THE CHARACTER
LONG BEACH GUY.
STILL HIS FAMILY DOWN THERE IN
THE LONG BEACH EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM FOR SURE FAMOUS LONG
BEACH FAMILY. AND.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S AS A
STATE PLAN THAT'LL BE OUR
MAGRITTE. OF RICE.
RE SOME SORRY FEDERAL POLICY.
LAYS ON CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU AND THEN
MONITORING LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCY OUTCOMES.
DAVID.
.
SAP I BELIEVE TO SAP.
DEPUTY DA POLICY DIRECTOR AND
ASSISTANT LEGAL COUNSEL STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION. AND
STEPHANIE.
.
GREGSON I HOPE I SAID THAT
CRACKED A CURRICULUM FRAMEWORK
INSTRUCTIONAL RESOURCES DIVISION
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. AND I THINK WE'LL
START WITH YOU MISTER ACTUALLY.
AND AGAIN IF YOU JUST STICK TO
THE TIMELINE THAT WE HAVE
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT OF
INFORMATION. A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO SHARE THIS
IMPORTANT INFORMATION THIS IS
KIND OF ACCOUNTABILITY IN A. IN
A BOX TODAY BECAUSE YOU WON'T
MAKE SURE WE COVER OUR BASES
HERE BECAUSE AGAIN WHEN I
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR. WHEN PEOPLE
OPPOSE OUR BILLS ARE GONNA SAY
WATCH THE ACCOUNTABILITY HEARING
SO I THANK YOU AGAIN FOR BEING
HERE YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY.
RIGHT ON.
WELCOME THIS AFTERNOON TO.
HE WAS APPROVED.
I CARE ACTUALLY THAT.
CALIFORNIA.
LISTEN I HAVE.
THE ONLY THING THAT WE STARTED
HEARING ACKNOWLEDGING.
HIS STRUGGLE.
LIKE IT'S STRUGGLE.
TNCS.
I QUALITY.
BOSTON'S.
CRITICAL ACCOUNTABILITY SO.
LOCAL CONTROL.
PLAN THAT EMPHASIZED.
AREAS MOVEMENT BY.
SURE.
ALSO.
WELL AS I PRESIDENT OBAMA
NGUYEN.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY BEFORE HIS.
ACCOUNTABILITY.
SPEAR HEADED BY THERE AM
SPEARHEADED BY THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA AND A DOCUMENT
THAT'S CALLED THE BLUEPRINT FOR
GREAT SCHOOLS.
THAT WAS.
AUTHORED BY A AND IT THE TO
ADVISORY GROUP A TO THE
SUPERINTENDENT.
THAT WHEN WE MADE A FUNDAMENTAL
SHIFT IN THE WAY THAT WE FUND
SCHOLS AND DISTRICTS IN THE
LOCAL DECISION MAKING THAT WE
GAVE YOU THAT WE'VE GIVEN TO
SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS AND THE
ASSISTANCE THAT WE PROVIDE TO
THEM.
SO CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT WE TO
UNDERSTAND CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT IT BE IMPORTANT FOR
UNDERSTAND WHERE WE CAME FROM
AND TO KNOWLEDGE WHERE WE CAME
FROM AND WHERE WE ARE NOW.
SO UNDER NCLB NO CHILD LEFT
BEHIND OF FEDERAL LAW AND PRIOR
TO.
LCF PFAFF WE HAD AN
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM THAT WAS
FEDERALLY DRIVEN.
IT WAS A VERY PRESCRIPTIVE.
I WANT YOU WERE IDENTIFIED FOR
ASSISTANCE AND YOUR ONE YOU HAD
TO DO SPECIFIC THINGS IN YOUR TO
YET TO DO SPECIFIC THINGS. THAN
THERE WERE CORRECTIVE ACTIONS IN
IT WAS A ONE SIZE FITS ALL
APPROACH.
WE WAS AN OVER RELIANCE ON THAT
SYSTEM ON TEST SCORES.
TEST SCORES AND GRADUATION
RATES WERE THE ONLY PART OF THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM. IN IT WAS
A SYSTEM OF CONSEQUENCES
YOU BASICALLY TESTS SKIDS AND
PROVIDE JUDGMENT ON HOW THAT
TESTING WENT.
UNDER THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA AND THE FLEXIBILITY
THAT'S PROVIDED UNDER.
* OUT THE EVERY STUDENT
SUCCEEDS ACT.
IT WE'VE NOW MOVED TO AN
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM OF
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT WHICH IS
STATE DRIVEN NOT FEDERALLY
DRIVEN IT'S BASED ON MULTIPLE
MEASURES NOT MOSTLY TEST SCORES
LIKE NCLB.
AND PROVIDING IN THOSE.
MULTIPLE MEASURES A CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL DASHBOARD THAT PROVIDES
FOR EVERY SCHOOL IN EVERY
DISTRICT IN MULTIPLE AREAS HOW
THAT'S IS THAT SCHOOL IS
PERFORMING NOT JUST CURRENTLY.
BUT.
IN TREND DATA AS WELL FROM THE
PREVIOUS YEAR TO NOW.
NOT ONLY THAT THE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM WITH THE
DASHBOARD PROVIDES FOR LOCAL
INDICATORS AS WELL AS STATE
INDICATORS FOR STATE INDICATORS
HAVE STATED THAT THE STATE HAS
IN THE STATE MAKE SOME SOME
CALCULATIONS INSTANT TENDER
DETERMINATIONS. AND PROVIDE SOME
DATA BACK TO COMMUNITIES ON HOW
THEY'RE DOING. BUT WE ADD TO
THAT AN ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM
HAS LOCAL INDICATORS BECAUSE
THERE'S INFORMATION OUT THERE
THAT IS NOT AVAILABLE TO THE
STATE.
LOCAL DATA SUCH AS HOW OUR
SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS
IMPLEMENTING THE STANDARDS HOW
ARE THEY DOING PROVIDING QUALITY
TEACHERS.
TO THEIR STUDENTS HOW ARE THEY
DOING ENGAGING THEIR COMMUNITY
AND THE SCHOOL AND THE SCHOOL
CLIMATE OR THE DISTRICT CLIMATE
AND WITHIN THAT ELLIE A.
AND THEN ALL OF THAT IS BASED ON
A CYCLE OF IMPROVEMENT.
A A SYSTEM THAT STARTS WITH
ASSESSMENT LOOKING AT DATA. THE
DELIVERY OF SOME SERVICE SOME
DESIGN OF THE SERVICES AND
DELIVERY OF THOSE SERVICES AND
THEN YOU EVALUATE HOW YOU'RE
DOING AND START THE CYCLE OVER
AGAIN TAKING A LOOK AT THE DATA
THAT YOU HAVE. TO MAKE A
DETERMINATION AS TO WHETHER YOU
SHOULD REDESIGN WHAT YOU'VE
PREVIOUSLY DONE.
SO ALL OF THAT.
OR IS THE ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM
BUT THEN ON NEXT TO THAT IS THE
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT WHICH WILL
TALK ABOUT LATER BUT JUST SOME
AN OVERVIEW OF THE DIFFERENCES
OF SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT. FROM THE
FEDERAL SYSTEM OF NO CHILD LEFT
BEHIND TO WHERE WE ARE NOW UNDER
LCF AFTER NASA.
UNDER THE OLD SYSTEM VERY UNEVEN
RESULTS THERE WAS SOME SUCCESS
BUT IT WAS LIMITED SUCCESS
WE GAVE LARGE GRANTS. PER OF THE
FEDERAL LAW TO INDIVIDUAL
SCHOOLS.
WHICH WAS FINE AND SOME OF THEM
SHOULD SOME OF THEM EVEN SHOWED
IMPROVEMENT BUT ONCE THE MONEY
ONE AWAY. OFTEN THE IMPROVEMENT
WENT AWAY AS WELL BECAUSE IT
DIDN'T FOCUS ON SYSTEMIC RESULTS
AND IT DIDN'T FOCUS ON WORKING
WITH THE SCHOOL DISTRICT.
COULD WHICH COULD HELP THE
SCHOOL OVER TIME.
TO MAKE THOSE GAINS A LONG TERM
AND SUSTAINABLE.
THE.
IT OFTEN FOCUSED ON TEAMS
COMING FROM THE OUTSIDE DROPPING
INTO A SCHOOL AND THEN TRYING TO
SOMEHOW ASSIST THEM AND WHAT TO
DO. AND IT IT IT ESTABLISH MORE
OF A CHECKLIST APPROACH THAN A
COLLABORATIVE APPROACH.
SO THATWAS THE OLD SYSTEM UNDER
THE NEW SYSTEM OF SUPPORT UNDER
LCF AFFAN THE LIMITED
FLEXIBILITY THAT AS A GIVES US.
ONE THERE'S MORE DATA AVAILABLE
TO THE SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS AND
WE CAN TALK ABOUT THAT. MORE IN
THE DASHBOARD.
THESE ARE KNOWN PARTNERS BECAUSE
THE FIRST LINE OF INTERVENTION
IS WITH THE COUNTY OFFICES
COUNTY OFFICES ARE VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
BECAUSE THEY'RE THE ONES THAT
APPROVED THEIR BUDGET ANDREA AB
TWELVE UNDER. THEIR THE ONES
THAT PROVE THEIR LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN ANNUALLY SO
THEY'RE ALREADY WELL.
IT WELL KNOWN
TE TO THAT SCHOOL DISTRICT
SO IT'S NOT JUST SOMEONE
DROPPING IN FROM THE OUTSIDE
THAT DOESN'T HAVE THE CONTEXT.
FOR WHAT IT IS LIKE A COUNTY
OFFICE DOES.
SO THESE ARE KNOWN PARTNERS THAT
CONTINUES TO BE A TEAM APPROACH
THAT'S A COLLABORATIVE APPROACH
TO TAKES A LOOK AND HELPS THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT IDENTIFY THEIR
ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS. IN A SELF
KIND OF A SELF DISCOVERY PROCESS
IT'S NOT WERE COMING IN AND THE
PERSON I THE SCHOOL DISTRICT IS
SAYING JUST TELL ME WHAT I
SUPPOSED TO DO.
THAT WAS KIND OF THAT'S KIND OF
THE OLD APPROACH NEW APPROACH IS
COMING ALONG SIDE. I'M FAMILIAR
WITH YOU I'M KNOWN TO YOU YOU'RE
KNOWN TO ME LET'S LOOK AT THE
DATA TOGETHER AND TOGETHER
DECIDE WHERE IT IS YOUR NEEDS
ARE AND AND DECIDE TOGETHER HOW
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE FORWARD AND
WANT TO TRY. TO.
AND TO IMPROVE.
HOW THINGS ARE GOING?
WITH THAT WE GET WHERE WE.
INVASION LONG TERM SOLUTIONS
VERSUS SHORT TERM.
SOLUTIONS
SO IT'S LOCAL PRIORITIES LOCAL
DECISIONS AND LOCAL TARGETS NOT
THINGS THAT ARE DESIGNED BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
OR THE EVER EVEN THE STATE HERE
IN SACRAMENTO BUT COUNTY OFFICES
AND APPEAR TO PEER APPROACH.
WE ALSO WANT TO DESIGN SOME
OTHER SYSTEMS AROUND IT LIKE OUR
CALIFORNIA DISTINGUISHED SCHOOLS
WE JUST RELEASED.
THIS WEEK A LIST OF TWO HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY SEVEN I BELIEVE THAT
THE SCHOOLS THAT WE'VE
IDENTIFIED AS DISTINGUISHED
SCHOOLS AND AN ADDITIONAL TWENTY
EIGHT I BELIEVE IT IS TWENTY
EIGHT EXEMPLARY DISTRICTS.
IS THE FIRST TIME WE'VE
IDENTIFIED DISTRICTS AND THE
EXEMPLARY DISTRICTS ARE THOSE
THAT HAVE ENGAGED GENUINELY.
IN THE SPIRIT OF LCF HAPPEN THE
LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLAN ENGAGING THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND MAKING A
DIFFERENCE FIRST THEIR SCHOOL IN
THEIR DISTRICT.
WE'RE HOPING THAT THOSE
DISTINGUISHED SCHOOLS CAN THEN
ASSESSED IN A PEER TO PEER
PASSION. THAT APPEARED HERE
FASHION WITH.
OTHER SCHOOLS THAT MAY NEED
ASSISTANCE
SEPARATELY IN THE AREAS OF THEIR
NEED.
SO OVERALL I'LL WRAP THIS UP
JUST JUST BY SAYING THAT ON.
THIS WHAT WE CALL THE CALIFORNIA
WAY IS.
TRUSTING EDUCATORS THAT KNOWING
THAT EDUCATORS WANT TO SUCCEED
TRUSTING THOSE EDUCATORS THAT
GIVEN THE PROPER.
SUPPORTS WILLED WILL.
WILL SUCCEED AND THEN PROVIDE
THEM THE LOCAL FLEXIBILITY FOR
DECISION MAKING IN ORDER TO MAKE
THE CHANGES THAT THEY NEED WHILE
THEY ENGAGE THEIR LOCAL
COMMUNITY AND DOING SO.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM
MARGUERITE REESE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AS WELL.
THAT AFTERNOON I WILL DESCRIBE
THE SST PLANNED DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS.
SO THAT EVERY STUDENT SUCCEEDS
ACTOR ASSET AS MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER I ACTUALLY MENTIONED IS
THE REAUTHORIZATION OF THE
ELEMENTARY AND SECONDARY
EDUCATION ACT OR ESEA WHICH I'M
IS THE PRIMARY FEDERAL EDUCATION
ON THE BEGAN IN NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE. AND WAS ONE OF THE FINAL
ACTS OF PRESIDENT OBAMA TO
REAUTHORIZE IN DECEMBER.
TWENTY FIFTEEN IT REPLACES THE
NO CHILD LEFT BEHIND ACT.
ITS PRIMARY FOCUS IS TO AND
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS AND
POPULATIONS AND IT'S MEANT TO
SUPPLEMENT NOT SUPPLANT STATE
PROGRAMS.
AT ALL STATES HAVE TO SUBMIT A
STATE PLAN TO THE US DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION AND I THINK AS MUCH
AS CALIFORNIA WISHES WE RECEIVED
A BLANK SHEET OF PAPER AND COULD
SHARE WHAT OUR PLAN IS WHAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. AND WE HAVE
A VERY STRICT AND STRUCTURE
TEMPLATE TO DESCRIBE AND HOW THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WILL BOTH
IMPLEMENT THE FEDERAL LAW AND
SPENDS THE FEDERAL ALLOCATION.
AT THAT CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
ENGAGED IN EIGHTEEN MONTHS OF
STAKEHOLDER INPUT I'M THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND FOR
PHASES TO DEVELOP THE FIRST
DRAFT OF THE STATE PLAN.
IN CALIFORNIA THE STATE PLAN
APPROVED EXCUSE ME THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION APPROVES THE
STATE PLAN IT'S A PROCESS BUT
NOT OTHERS MANY OTHER STATESGO
THROUGH. AND BUT IT'S WORTH
NOTING THAT THERE'S OF THAT
EXTRA LAYER OF APPROVAL.
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN CALIFORNIA
STATES WERE ALLOWED TO SUBMIT TO
IN ONE OF TWO WINDOWS EITHER
APRIL OR SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN OF LAST YEAR. FOR
SEVERAL REASONS CALIFORNIA CHOSE
TO BE A SEPTEMBER SUBMISSION
STATE AND SO THE FIRST VERSION
OF THE STATE PLAN WAS APPROVED
BY THE STATE BOARD IN SEPTEMBER.
AND WAS SUBMITTED TO THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION UM WE
RECEIVED WORD JUST A FEW DAYS
BEFORE THE WINTER HOLIDAY THAT
THE US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
HAD SOME FEEDBACK FOR S..
ALLSTATE'S RECEIVED SOME DEGREE
OF FEEDBACK NO ONE TURNED IN OUR
STATE PLAN AND IMMEDIATELY HAD
IT APPROVED BY SECRETARY TO
BOSS.
CALIFORNIA CONSIDERED THAT.
FEEDBACK AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION BROUGHT FORWARD A
REVISED VERSION OR YOU MIGHT
CALL IT VERSION TO.
TO THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION.
IN MARCH OF THIS YEAR.
.
IN THE INTERIM. THE ONE OF THE
BENEFITS OF MY POSITION IS THAT
I GET TO SPEAK REGULARLY WITH MY
COUNTERPARTS FROM OTHER STATES
OTHER FEDERAL LIAISONS AND WHAT
I LEARNED IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS
AND WHAT OTHER STATES WERE
ENGAGING IN. IS IN THIS PERIOD
BETWEEN SUBMITTING A STATE PLAN.
AND GAINING APPROVAL MANY
STATES WERE AND BASED ON THE
FEEDBACK THEY HAD RECEIVED FROM
THE US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
SENDING SORT OF DRAFTS BACK AND
FORTH AND ENTERING INTO
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
ESSENTIALLY SAY. WOULD YOU BE
OKAY WITH THIS.
AN EX CENTER AND SO KNOWING
THAT A SMALL TEAM FROM THE STATE
BOARD OF EDUCATION.
AND THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TRAVELED TO THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
IN FEBRUARY AND.
BEGAN THOSE FORMAL NEGOTIATIONS
AND THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION STAFF WHAT THAT MET
WITH US FOR ABOUT SIX HOURS ON
THAT DAY AND CONVERSATIONS
CONTINUED.
REALLY UP TO THIS DAY BUT I'M
CERTAINLY PRIOR TO THE MARCH
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION
MEETING.
THE BOARD CONSIDERED.
CHANGES TO WHAT SORT OF IS THE
VERSION TWO OF THE STATE PLAN.
MOST OF THE AREAS OF CHANGE ARE
FEEDBACK FROM THE US DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION WHERE RELATED TO
THE ACCOUNTABILITY SECTIONS OF
OUR S. A STATE PLAN.
SUGGESTED CHANGES RELATED TO
AND THE IDENTIFICATION OF
SCHOOLS FROM PROVE MEANT OUR
ENGLISH LEARNER PROGRESS
INDICATOR.
HOW WE DISPLAY STATUS AND
CHANGE ARE JUST A FEW EXAMPLES?
GIVEN THE TIMING OF WHEN THE
MATERIALS WERE POSTED IN THE
STATE BOARD MEETING IN MARCH THE
BOARD.
VOTED TO APPROVE A HANDFUL OF
TECHNICAL CHANGES AND THE
DECISION WAS MADE THAT IN A
PROBLEM.
THE BOARD WOULD CONSIDER THE
REMAINING AND FRANKLY MORE
SIGNIFICANT.
SECTIONS OF THE REVISIONS TO
THE STATE PLAN SO ON APRIL
TWELFTH AND THE BOARD WILL TAKE
A LOOK AT WHAT IS ESSENTIALLY
VERSION THREE. OF THE STATE PLAN
AND THEY WILL.
IF ALL GOES ACCORDING TO PLAN.
APPROVE THE STATE PLAN AND
SHORTLY THEREAFTER CALIFORNIA
WILL SUBMIT WHAT WE HOPE IS THE
FINAL VERSION.
TO DATE THIRTY SEVEN STATES
PLUS PORTO RICO EM HAVE HAD
THEIR STATE PLANS APPROVED BY
THE US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
AND AS I MENTIONED THINGS JUST
TAKE A LITTLE LONGER IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE OF THE.
APPROVAL OF THE STATE BOARD.
AS WELL AS WE CHOSE TO BE ONE
OF THE SECOND WINDOW OF
SUBMISSION STATES IN SEPTEMBER.
SO BASED OUR NEGOTIATIONS WITH
THE US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
THE DEPARTMENT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION FEELS
VERY CONFIDENT THAT THE VERSION
THAT IS IN PRINT THAT WILL BE
BEFORE THE BOARD ON APRIL
TWELFTH. IS TRULY IN A PROVABLE
STATE PLAN WE'VE HAD COUNTLESS
HOURS OF CONVERSATIONS AND
MEETINGS AND CORRESPONDENCE WITH
THE US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
AND NOW THEY HAVE NOT FORMALLY
APPROVED OUR STATE PLAN.
WE HAVE WORKED WITH THEM TO
DEVELOP THE LANGUAGE AND FEEL
THAT WHAT WE ARE BRINGING TO THE
BOARD AND WHAT WILL ULTIMATELY
BE SENT TO THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. IS AN OF PROVABLE
PLAN.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM.
DAVID SAP DEPUTY POLICY
DIRECTOR AND ASSISTANT LEGAL
COUNSEL FOR THE STATE BOARD OF
EDUCATION AND STEPHANIE GRAYSON
CURRICULUM FRAMEWORK AND
INSTRUCTIONAL RESOURCES DIVISION
OF CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION YOU MAY BOTH.
SO I'M GOING TO START BUT GOOD
AFTERNOON AND I'M GOING TO KIND
OF GO OVER THE CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
A SUPPORT AND HOW THE LOCAL
CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN. AND
OUR MONITORING OF ONLY A
SUCCESSES IS INCORPORATED INTO
OUR SYSTEM SUPPORT SO IN ORDER
TO IMPROVE THE EDUCATION OF OUR
STUDENTS. CALIFORNIA'S IN THE
PROCESS OF CREATING A
COORDINATED AND COHERENT STATE
STRUCTURE TO INSERT SURE THAT
OUR LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES.
RECEIVE RESOURCES AND SUPPORT TO
MEET IDENTIFIED STUDENT NEEDS
INCLUDING THE DISPARITIES AND
OUTCOMES OR OPPORTUNITIES AND
THAT THIS IS GROUNDED IN A
COLLABORATIVE AND. BUILDING
CAPACITY APPROACH
THE LC FSA FF IS THE FOUNDATION
FOR RE EMERGING CALIFORNIA'S
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT SYSTEM AS A RESULT
OF THE LC FF CALIFORNIA WORKED
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP
TOOLS FOR EDUCATORS. TO USE TO
HELP IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
STUDENTS INCLUDING THE LOCAL
CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN AND
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD
IN ADDITION TO THOSE TOOLS AND A
NEW FUNDING FORMULA. THE LCF
I'VE OUTLINED DIVERT VISION FOR
SUPPORT ASSISTANCE AND THE
SYSTEM IS SUPPORT HAS THREE
LEVELS WE'VE LEVEL ONE AND THESE
ARE RESOURCES AND SUPPORTS IT
EVERY SINGLE SOON ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND TEACHERS HAVE
ACCESS TO. WE HAVE LEVEL TO THAT
IS DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE
IT'S WHERE OUR SUPPORT PROVIDERS
COULD BE THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS THAT CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION CHARTER
AUTHORIZED EARNERS AND THEY
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE PROVIDE
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE. FOR
THOSE ELOISE IN SCHOOLS IN THE
FORM OF INDIVIDUALLY DESIGNED
ASSISTANCE
TO ADDRESS IDENTIFIED
PERFORMANCE ISSUES AND THEN
LEVEL THREE IS THAT INTENSIVE
INTERVENTION SUPPORT WHAT THE
STATE SUPERINTENDENT FOR PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION OR FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS. THE CHARTER AUTHORIZED
OR MAY REQUIRE MORE INTENSIVE
INTERVENTIONS FOR ELEAZAR OR
SCHOOLS WITH PERSISTENT
PERFORMANCE ISSUES OVER A
SPECIFIED TIME PERIOD.
THE GOAL FOR THE SUPPORT OF ALL
LEVELS IS TO ASSIST ELEAZER IN
THEIR SCHOOLS TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF EACH STUDENT SERVED WITH A
FOCUS ON BUILDING CAPACITY TO
SUSTAIN IMPROVEMENT AND
EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS INEQUITIES
AND SOON OPPORTUNITIES AND
OUTCOMES. THIS MEANS THAT THE
OUTCOMES FOR THIS WORK INCLUDE
NOT ONLY IMPROVEMENT ON
DESPERATE INDICATORS FROM YEAR
TO YEAR BUT ALSO PROGRESSING ON
INTERIM MEASUREMENTS. THE ALLEYS
COLLECT LOCALLY AND USE
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS THAT THE
DASHBOARD CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR OUR LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES
TO ELEVATE THEIR LOCAL DATA AND
CREATE LOCAL DATA THAT CAN USE.
THAT CAN BE USED TO WATER THEIR
GOALS ON SPECIFIC OUTCOMES AND
MEASURES THROUGHOUT THEIR ENTIRE
YEAR SO NOT JUST WAITING FOR ONE
ASSESSMENT THEY CAN UC'S
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE YEAR. AND
IN ORDER TO IT STACCATO COURTNEY
SUPPORTED ALL OF THESE LEVELS
THE AGENCIES CHARGED WITH
REPORTING PROVIDING THE SUPPORT
UNDER THE LCF I HAVE EXPANDED
THEIR INITIAL CROSS AGENCY
GROUP.
TO INCLUDE STAKEHOLDER
PERSPECTIVES AND PRACTITIONERS
FROM THE FIELDS AND THIS LARGER
TEAM IS THE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT
PLANNING GROUP AND IS INTENDED
TO ADDRESS COMMON CONCERNS AND
INTERESTS FROM THE FIELD
REGARDING SUPPORT FOR ELOISE IN
SCHOOLS. AND THE ELEMENTS OF THE
SUPPORT FOR THESE DISTINGUISHING
AREAS OF WORK THAT WILL CURRENT
THE SYSTEM A SUPPORT INCLUDE
THAT RECALLS ANALYSIS THAT
CARICATURE BLAMED THAT PATHWAYS
TO SUPPORT ASSISTANCE BECAUSE
NOT EVERY ALLEY A HAS THE SAME
ACCESS.
TO SUPPORT AND SO WE'RE MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE EQUITY OF
ACCESS TO THE SUPPORTS THE
INITIAL OUTREACH TO ELEAZAR THE
REVIEW OF DATA THAT SUPPORTS
ALLEYWAYS IN THEIR SCHOOLS TO
IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES.
AND CALIFORNIA'S APPROACH TO
ASSISTANCE UNDER LC FF DIFFERS
GREATLY FROM THE PAST AND IS A
FORMER PRINCIPAL OF A SCHOOL
THAT WAS UNDER LCL BE.
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM I CAN
HONESTLY SAY THIS IS A VERY
DIFFERENT APPROACH IS ABOUT
GETTING IN WITH THE LA AND
HELPING THEM DETERMINE WHAT ARE
THE ROOT CAUSES WHAT ARE THEIR
BARRIERS. TO PROVIDING QUALITY
INSTRUCTION TO EVERY SINGLE
STUDENT AT THEIR SCHOOL SO THIS
IS A VERY EXCITING OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE THE THE THREE OF THESE
KEY STEPS REFLECT THAT. THE
INTENT THAT DIFFERENTIATED
ASSISTANCE TO TAILOR IT TO BE
TAYLOR TO LOCALLY IDENTIFIED
NEEDS RATHER THAN IMPOSE AS A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL.
SOLUTION SO THAT SOME OF THESE.
SHIPS INCLUDE SUPPORT PROVIDERS
WORKING ALONGSIDE ELEAZAR AND
THEIR SCHOOLS TO IDENTIFY KEY
CHALLENGES AND OPPORTUNITIES
USING A SYSTEMIC APPROACH
SIMILAR TO LOCALLY IDENTIFIED
NEEDS AND STRENGTHS BECAUSE
EVERY SINGLE DISTRICT IS
DIFFERENT. THEIR ISSUES ARE
DIFFERENT AND THEIR STRENGTHS
ARE DIFFERENT AND ENGAGING WITH
THE LOCAL EDUCATORS AND
COMMUNITY IS AS PART OF THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
SO STOP THERE BECAUSE I KNOW YOU
PROBABLY HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS
BUT IT'S A REALLY EXCITING
OPPORTUNITY FOR US AS CD
AN ALLEY A SPEEDY ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN A SYSTEM. THAT IS
GOING TO BE INDIVIDUALIZED FOR
EVERY SINGLE SCHOOL.
THANK YOU.
SAP GOOD AFTERNOON I'M I'D LIKE
TO FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON THREE
ISSUES FIRST JUST THE BILL A
LITTLE BIT ON WHAT MISTER
GREGSON SHARED ABOUT THE SYSTEM
OF SUPPORT WITHIN THE
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM. THOSE
THREE LEVELS OF ASSISTANCE THAT
BUT THAT SHE DESCRIBED THE
SUPPORT FOR ALL WEREN'T DEAD. IT
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE AN
INTENSIVE INTERVENTION VERY
SIMILAR TO THE APPROACH FOR
MULTI TIERED SYSTEM OF SUPPORT
WHICH IS A FRAMEWORK THAT USE
FOR DELIVERY OF INSTRUCTION AND
SERVICES IN THE CLASSROOM AND
SCHOOL LEVEL. SO IT'S A FAMILIAR
CONCEPT TO EDUCATORS THAT SORT
OF HAS BEEN INCORPORATED AS THE
FRAME FOR OVERALL SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT. AND ONE THING THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT ABOUT THAT
DECISION IS TO NOT LOSE SIGHT OF
THE SUPPORT FOR ALL WHICH IS
THERE'S LEVEL WINDS SUPPORTS.
WHAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
HAPPENS IS THAT YOUR WRITING
GENERAL SUPPORT ABOUT HOW TO
PROVIDE QUALITY INSTRUCTION TO
ENGLISH LEARNERS IT'S NOT
TOTALLY DIFFERENT FROM WHAT
WE'RE COMMUNICATING ABOUT HOW
BRIGHT QUALITY INSTRUCTION ON
SPECIAL EDUCATION? SO THIS IDEA
OF ALIGNING IN COORDINATING
SUPPORTS THREE IS INTEGRATED
SYSTEM WE BELIEVE IS THE
STARTING POINT IS WHAT YOU
PROVIDE FOR ALL IN YOU BUILD ON
THAT WHEN YOU PROVIDE
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE TO
ENSURE THERE'S LESS OF A
CONSISTENT APPROACH. AS FAR AS
HOW I WERE ASKING LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES TO SUPPORT
STUDENTS.
SECOND OR JUST A HIGH WEIGHT ON
THE CROSS AGENCY GROUP THAT MISS
GREGSON REFERENCED.
THAT'S INITIALLY STARTED WITH
THE AGENCIES THAT ARE CHARGED BY
STATUTE WITH PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE INITIATE ITS BEEN
EXPANDED TO INCLUDE
STAKEHOLDERS.
AND WE THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WERE MODELING
THE ENGAGEMENT THAT WE EXPECT
ELEAZAR HAVE AND THEIR
DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS. ENSURING
THAT STAKEHOLDERS ARE ENGAGED IN
THE PROCESS HELPING TO IDENTIFY
AREAS OF NEED IN PLACES THAT THE
AGENCIES THEMSELVES CAN FOCUS ON
A COORDINATE BETTER ON. AND
PROVIDING SUPPORT.
AND AS HAS BEEN NOTED THIS
APPROACH IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM
WHAT WE'VE DONE THE PAST I THINK
WHAT I LIKE TO THINK ABOUT IS
THAT IN CONTRAST THE PAST OUR
CURRENT SYSTEM. INSISTS THAT
LOCAL DECISION MAKERS OWN THE
CHALLENGES AND TOGETHER WITH
THEIR STAKEHOLDERS IDENTIFY
UNDERLYING CAUSES FOR LOW
STUDENT PERFORMANCE AND DEVELOP
SOLUTIONS THAT THEY'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IMPLEMENTING. IN
THE ROLE FOR THE STATE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT. IS TO COORDINATE AND
PROVIDE ASSISTANCE THAT'S
RESPONSIVE TO THIS LIKELY
IDENTIFIED NEEDS.
THE SECOND POINT I TALK ABOUT IS
WHERE WE ARE IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF LCF HALF
TWENTY THIRTEEN WAS WHEN THE LAW
WAS PASSED WORKS ARE GETTING
INTO THE THAT. THAT YEAR
ESSENTIALLY HERE FIVE
IMPLEMENTATION.
THE TWO TOOLS THAT SORT OF TELL
CFF CALLED FOR THE LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS THAT THAT
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES MUST
ADOPT AND AN UPDATE ANNUALLY AS
WELL AS THE EVALUATION RUBRICS
WHICH NASH UP IN THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL DASHBOARD THAT YOU'VE
HEARD DESCRIBED.
THOSE WERE ALWAYS INTENDED TO
WORK TOGETHER THAT THE DATA IT
REFLECTED IN THE DASHBOARD IS
USED TO INFORM THE DEVELOPMENT
OF THE LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLAN.
IT IS THE TASK FORCE ACTUALLY
COMPLETES THE LOCAL PLANNING
PROCESS THE WAY IT WAS ALWAYS
INTENDED WHEN LCF ACT WAS
PASSED.
BUT THE FALL TWENTY SEVENTEEN
DASHBOARD WHICH WAS RELEASED IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN WAS
THE FIRST OPERATIONAL RELEASE OF
THE DASHBOARD THE FIRST YEAR
WHERE THE DEEP WHERE THE GAS WAS
RELEASED WITH DATA FROM THE
PRIOR YEAR.
SO REALLY THIS IS THE FIRST TIME
THAT THE SYSTEM WITH THOSE TOO
STATE KEY STATE TOOLS ARE
WORKING IN CONCERT TOGETHER AND
WE BELIEVE WILL VERY MUCH
STRENGTH AND. THE LOCAL PLANNING
PROCESS AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN
PARTICULARLY ENHANCE AND MAKE
MORE RICH THE DISCUSSIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS BECAUSE THAT DATA
PROVIDED REALLY HELP FOCUS WHERE
THERE'S LOCAL CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT HOW TO USE RESOURCES. TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS
SHOULD BE FOCUSED.
AND THE FINAL POINT IS YOU KNOW
MAYBE YOU'RE THINKING THIS
SOUNDS NICE BUT WHAT DOES IT
LOOK LIKE AND HOW DOES THIS MAKE
A DIFFERENCE FOR STUDENTS IN
CLASSROOMS.
I THINK WITH THE WE HAD A LOT OF
FOCUS ON WHAT LIES AHEAD WHICH
WE OFTEN LOSE SIGHT OF THIS
ACTUALLY LIVE TODAY COUNTIES AND
DISTRICTS THAT WERE IDENTIFIED
AS HER DISTRICTS ARE DEFINED AS
NEEDING EXTRA ASSISTANCE. ON THE
DASHBOARD OF WORKING WITH
COUNTIES AS WE SPEAK
SO I'D LIKE TO JUST POINT TO AN
EXAMPLE JUST TO ILLUSTRATE THIS
DIFFERENT APPROACH THAT YOU'VE
HEARD DESCRIBED BEFORE NOW THIS
IS AN EXAMPLE. FROM ONE OF THE
NETWORKS THAT THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE FOR EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE IS FACILITATING BUT
THE APPROACH IS VERY SIMILAR TO
HOW COUNTIES ARE WORKING
INDIVIDUALLY WITH DISTRICTS
IDENTIFIED ON THE DASHBOARD.
IN THIS EXAMPLE DISTRICT STAFF
HAD COMPLETED A REVIEW OF DAY AT
AROUND SIX REALLY TROUBLING
SUSPENSION RATES AND WHAT IT
UNDERLYING CAUSES.
AT THE LAST SESSION THAT COME UP
WITH ISSUES THAT ARE PRETTY MUCH
OUTSIDE THE CONTROL OF THE
SCHOOL ITSELF. GENERATIONAL
POVERTY GUY GENERATIONAL POVERTY
LIMITED PARENT INVOLVEMENT
LANGUAGE BARRIERS FOR EXAMPLE.
AT THE START OF THE NEXT SESSION
THE FACILITATOR RELIGIOUS
REFRAIN THE DISCUSSION IS SAID
YOU KNOW THAT'S ALL STUFF IT'S
OUTSIDE OUR OF YOUR CONTROL
LET'S FOCUS ON THINGS THAT
SCHOOL TIDBITS THE SCHOOL ITSELF
CAN CONTROL.
THIS PROMPTED A RECOGNITION THAT
THEY WERE FOCUSED ON EXTERNAL
FACTORS IN COULD INSTEAD BE
FOCUSING ON THINGS THAT THEY
THEMSELVES. COULD CONTROL FOR
EXAMPLE SCHOOL CULTURE AN
APPLICATION OF SUSPENSION
POLICIES.
THEY SHIFTED THE DISCUSSION FROM
THINGS THAT WERE EXTERNAL TO THE
SCHOOL TO THINGS THAT THEY DID
HAVE CONTROL OVER AND REALLY
MOVED INTO A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
DISCUSSION. ABOUT HOW THEY COULD
USE DATA TO INFORM THEIR OWN
DECISION MAKING.
THIS IS A REALLY DIFFERENT
CONVERSATION FROM WHAT WOULD
OCCUR IF SOMEONE SHOULD UP WITH
A CLIPBOARD IN THE CHECKLIST AND
SAID HERE'S WHAT YOU NEED TO DO
OUR PROGRAM THAT YOU NEED TO
IMPLEMENT AS A SOLUTION.
SIMILAR CONVERSATIONS WITH HER
ABOUT MINDSET IN CULTURE SHIFT
ARE TAKING PLACE ACROSS THE
STATE AS WE SPEAK.
AND THEY'RE LAYING THE
FOUNDATION FOR THE REALLY HARD
WORK THAT WE HAVE AHEAD OF US IS
A STATE OF DESIGNING AND
IMPLEMENTING EDUCATION PROGRAMS
AND RESPONSIVE TO STUDENT NEED.
AND IN DOING THAT THAT'S HOW
WE'RE GONNA MAKE PROGRESS IN
NARROWING THE PERFORMANCE GAPS
THAT WE'VE BEEN STRUGGLE WITH IS
THE STATE STATE FOR DECADES. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND LOOK
TOWARDS YOUR QUESTIONS.
GREAT THANK YOU ARE VERY WELL
DONE ALL THE PANEL MEMBERS ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE PANEL.
CENTER MORE LOCKED.
IF YOU WISH CHAIR JUST JUST A
COUPLE QUICK QUESTIONS.
YOU DON'T PROVIDE POLICE THE
MATURE I HAVE A AN EXAMPLE OF
WHAT A DASHBOARD LOOKS LIKE.
AND SO.
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL. OF
BECAUSE I AM GETTING. CONCERNED
FROM PARENTS WERE SAYING IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT.
TO WORK THROUGH THAT THE
DASHBOARD BUT I I'M JUST CHRIS
WHAT IS BEING MEASURED. AND
THEN.
SINCE I'M WILL ANAL ON ON PAGE.
SEVEN OF TWELVE IN YOUR.
MONITORING ELLIE OUT ELLIE A
OUTCOMES YOU HAVE A GRAPH THAT
SAYS AMONG CALIFORNIA DISTRICTS.
SIX HUNDRED AND THREE HAD LOW
RATINGS FOR MATH OR ENGLISH.
THAT'S I'M JUST RUNNING TO MAYBE
YOU CAN EXPLAIN THAT PAGE
SOMEONE.
OR PERHAPS THAT'S IN THE PACKET
WE WILL SEE WHAT IS THE PAGE
NUMBER.
SAYS SEVEN OF TWELVE.
IT'S DATED MARCH TWENTY THIRD
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO FIFTY FIVE PM
IT'S ABOUT HALFWAY THROUGH THE
THIRD SEX.
IT'S GOT A BAR CHART.
WE'RE GETTING A PACKET SO WE CAN
SEE WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO IT.
BACK.
THAT'S IT.
WE GIVE THEM A PACKET. SINCE
ARE YOU HAVE EXCELLENCE.
GIVEN THE WEB ALIVE WHAT TABS
IT'S IT'S.
IT'S RIGHT IN FRONT MONITORING
LA A QUESTION.
WELCOME TO SCHOOL DASHBOARD TEST
SCORE RATINGS.
AND SO I BELIEVE WE HAVE ELEVEN
HUNDRED SCHOOL DISTRICTS
APPROXIMATELY.
NO MORE THAN HALF OF THEM ARE.
YOU HAD LOW RATINGS FOR MATH OR
ENGLISH I JUST MAYBE SOMEONE
COULD JUST COMMENT.
SO.
THIS SO I I THINK I THINK WITH
THIS CHART IT COMES FROM A NEWS
ARTICLE THAT DID AN ANALYSIS OF
THE DASHBOARD DATE I BELIEVE
LOOKING AT IT. AND WHAT THIS
SHOWS IS ACTUALLY INFORMATION
THAT IS REPORTED ON THE
DASHBOARD WHICH IS IF ED IF IT
DISTRICT OR A SCHOOL OR ANY
STUDENT GROUP WITHIN DISTRICT OR
SCHOOL. IS PERFORMING LOW ON ANY
OF THE INDICATORS THAT DASHBOARD
INCLUDES MULTIPLE MEASURES
INCLUDING TEST SCORES THE TEST
SCORES IS A VERY IMPORTANT
INDICATOR. AND ACCOUNTABILITY
SYSTEM BUT IT'S NO LONGER THE
ONLY INDICATOR SUCCESS.
SO THIS IS ACTUALLY AS PART OF
THE ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM WORK
ANNUALLY REPORTING DATA WE USED
TO USING COLORS ARE RED BEING
THE LOWEST WORD MARKETING
SLIGHTLY BETTER BUT STILL LOW.
AND SO THIS IS TILING THAT WE
HAVE A LOT OF DISTRICTS ACROSS
THE STATE THAT ARE STRUGGLING ON
ASSESSMENTS.
AND ONE THING THAT I THINK IS
IT IS IMPORTANT GOING BACK TO
POINT I MADE ABOUT THE LEVEL ONE
THE SUPPORT FOR ALL. THE STATE
BOARD REVISE THE A PLAN TEMPLATE
FOR THE LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLANS TO EVERY YEAR. DISTRICTS
NOW WE HAVE A DASHBOARD HAVE TO
LOOK AT THEIR DOUBTS WERE DATA
AND IF THERE'S A SINGLE
INDICATOR WHERE THEY HAVE A RED
OR ORANGE WHICH OF THOSE TWO
LOWEST PERFORMANCE LEVELS. THE
NEED TO ADDRESS IN THEIR LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLANS WHAT
THEY'RE DOING TO ADDRESS THAT
WITH THAT INDICATOR OF LIEU OF
LIVE PERFORMANCE.
AS FAR AS OUR OVERALL
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM WE'RE
LOOKING AT LEAST
TWO INDICATORS WHERE DISTRICT TO
STRUGGLING AS FAR AS THAT'S WHAT
THE STATUTE HEALTHY FF ITSELF IN
STATUTE. SAID THAT THE
ASSISTANCE FROM COUNTIES WHAT
WE'RE CALLING THAT LEVEL TO
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE WE
LOOK AT WHETHER A STUDENT GROUP
IN A DISTRICT IS STRUGGLING ON
AT LEAST TWO MEASURES.
SO IF THERE AND READ IT
BASICALLY ON TO THESE DASHBOARD
MEASURES THAT URBAN I IN
MEASURING DIFFERENT THINGS A
TEST SCORES AND SUSPENSION RATE
OR TEST SCORES IN GRAD RATE.
THAT'S WHEN COUNTIES REQUIRED TO
COME IN AND OFFER ASSISTANCE
BUT EVEN IF THEY DON'T GET
COUNTY ASSISTANCE THEIR REQUIRED
ANNUALLY THROUGH THEIR LOCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN PROCESS.
ENGAGING WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO
LOOK AT THAT DATA REFLECT ON IT
AND DESCRIBE HOW THEIR
ADDRESSING IT IN THEIR OWN LOCAL
PLAN.
FOR THE NUMBER I CAN ASSUME YOU
DIDN'T PUT THIS.
.
BOOK TOGETHER NO CENTER MORE
LACK OF HIT APOLOGIZE I ASSUME
THAT THIS WAS SOMETHING YOU
COLLABORATED ON IT.
AND GAVE TO ASIDE I DID MEAN TO
PUT YOU ON THE SPOT THEN THE
COULD COULD YOU EXPLAIN MAYBE
THIS GRAPH.
A BUSINESS A ONE FOR ONE.
AT THAT THERE MAYBE ARE MORE
LATINO STUDENTS AT THIS
PARTICULAR SCHOOL.
SO I.
I WOULD WANT TO TAKE A CLOSER
LOOK AT THE UNDERLYING DATA.
TO TO BE CONFIDENT IN AND
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION BUT I I
BELIEVE THAT BUT IF YOU IF
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE OVERALL
PERFORMANCE OF A DISTRICT.
THAT'S HOW ALL STUDENTS ARE
DOING SO THAT IS A WE WE THE
DASHBOARD PROVIDES A COLOR FOR
ALL STUDENT IT ALSO PROVIDES
COLORS JUST FOR INDIVIDUAL
STUDENT GROUPS IF THEY HAD AT
LEAST THIRTY STUDENTS SO. THAT
ASK FOR REPORTS DATA BOTH FOR
OVERALL PERFORMANCE IN
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT GROUP
PERFORMANCE
THIS WOULD BE LIKE.
ALL SIX HUNDRED DISTRICTS.
THAT WERE SAMPLED.
NOT SO MYSELF I CAN YOU'RE TIRED
AND YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS
BAR CHART CORRECT JACQUELINE
YEAH SO UNDERSTOOD JUST TO BE
CLEAR AND. WHAT IT SAYS AND
AGAIN I HAVE? I DIDN'T DO THIS
REPORT BUT WHAT IT SAYS IS IT'S
MATH OR. READING ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ARTS SO IT'S NOT BOTH
OF ITS ONE OR THE OTHER WE
ACTUALLY HAVE ABOUT A THOUSAND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND ANOTHER.
THOUSAND OR CLOSE TO CHARTER
SCHOOLS CHARTER SCHOOLS GET
THEIR OWN DASHBOARD AS WELL IT'S
NOT ROLLED UP THEIR DISTRICT
THEY GET THEIR OWN. BECAUSE
THEY'RE REQUIRED TO DO THEIR OWN
LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLAN.
IN THIS THIS REFERS TO NOT
OVERALL SCORES BUT WHAT IS THIS
THIS IS SAYING IS AB THREE SIX
HUNDRED AND THREE.
IN THESE THREE HUNDRED SIX
HUNDRED THREE DISTRICTS THEY HAD
AT LEAST ONE OF THOSE STUDENT
GROUPS END UP IN THE RATHER THE
ORANGE SO OVERALL THEY MAY BE
DOING VERY WELL AND THIS IS THE.
THE VERY INTENT OF THE DASHBOARD
OVERALL THEY MAY BE DOING VERY
WELL BUT IF THEY HAVE A STUDENT
INDIVIDUAL STUDENT GROUP VIET
ENGLISH LEARNERS SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENT RACE AND
ETHNICITY WHATEVER IT IS. THAT'S
IN THE RED ORANGE THEY NEED TO
ADDRESS THAT IT'S NOT GOOD
ENOUGH TO SAY WILL OVERALL WERE
DOING WELL.
SO THIS PARTICULAR CHART POINTS
OUT THOSE THAT HAD ONE OR MORE
OF ONE OF THOSE STUDENT GROUPS.
DONALD WHEN THE RHETORIC BAR
THEN THAT HAS ANY COLOR
DIFFERENTIATION IS AFRICAN
AMERICAN SO WHAT WOULD THAT
MEAN.
BUT IT WOULD HELP MAYBE HAVE
MORE STUDENTS THAT HAVE ISSUES
ON THAT PARTICULAR BAR.
IT'S SO IT IS SET SO THIS CHART
SHOWS THAT CUT THE TWO COLORS IN
THE BARS ARE JUST DISTRICTS OVER
ALL IN DISTRICTS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED TO RECEIVE ASSISTANCE
FROM COUNTIES SO THE LIGHTER
COLOR IN THIS IS THERE IS THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED TO RECEIVE
ASSISTANCE FROM COUNTIES.
THANK YOU RICHARD
GREAT THANK YOU JUST JUST
TREMONT FRYING CLARIFICATION TO
A SUB GROUP IS DEFINED AS THIRTY
OR MORE AT A SCHOOL OR ADDED IN
A DISTRICT.
WELL IN EITHER CASE
A EITHER.
OKAY MORE AND MORE EITHER.
YEAH UNDERSTOOD VERY WELL DONE.
I THINK SENATOR ALLEN.
WHO HAS JOINED US I WANTED TO?
YEAH I WANTED TO AND.
TWO IS TO TALK A BIT MORE ABOUT
YOU KNOW.
HOW WE MAKE THE STASHED FOR MORE
USER FRIENDLY AND I THINK WE
HAVE WHO THE VISIT I DON'T?
DISAGREE THAT THE MOVE AWAY FROM
A SINGLE.
NUMBER THAT.
OSTENSIBLY SUMMED UP ALL OF THE
PLUSES AND MINUSES MINUSES OF AN
INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL OR INDIVIDUAL
ENTITY WAS AND. WAS OVERLY
SIMPLE SIMPLISTIC I I I I I I I
THINK THAT TIME. IT WAS OVERLY
SIMPLISTIC BUT.
I'M BUT I THINK THAT.
BUT AT THE HEART OF SOME OF THE
EDUCATION OF THE THE FEDERAL
EDUCATION APARTMENTS CONCERNS.
WHO WERE? WORDS DID IT THEY DID
ULTIMATELY THIS THE DASHBOARD
THIS IS JUST IT'S BEEN SO
COMPLICATED.
THAT IT REALLY GIVES.
YOU KNOW LEASES ORIGINALLY
PROPOSED EARLY GAVE NO CLEAR
IDEA OF HOW WELL A SCHOOL IS
FUNCTIONING OVERALL IN AND.
I.
I THINK WAS VERY DIFFICULT FOR
PARENTS TO.
INTERPRET. OR UNDERSTAND.
I'M.
SO OUR I I WANNA GET A LITTLE
BIT DOWN INTO THAT QUESTION YOU
KNOW WILL. WE IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
US AS POLICYMAKERS AND FOR BOARD
MEMBERS IN.
OUR FOLKS IN THE VARIOUS LEVELS
OF THE. EDUCATIONAL GOVERNMENT'S
BUREAUCRACY TO UNDERSTAND AND
AND BE ABLE TO TO MONITOR
PROGRESS AT SCHOOLS NOW BUT
THERE'S ALSO A KIND OF BROADER
PUBLIC.
ASPECT OF THIS AND AS IT RELATES
TO PARENTS AND STUDENTS AND WHAT
ARE WE DOING TO TO TRULY MAKE
THIS SYSTEM MORE USER FRIENDLY
FOR PARENTS WHILE ALSO.
RECOGNIZINGTHE COMPLEXITY OF
THE WORK.
I'D BE GLAD IF THE START YEAH.
SO.
.
SO FIRST.
EH SOME OF THE RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT THAT THAT THE PARENTS SIR
ARE LOOKING FAVORABLY ON THE
DASHBOARD.
SO IT'S NOT ALL IS CERTAINLY NOT
ALL PARENTS AT ME WHEN HE WAS
THE REASON WOULD RESEARCH IS.
THAT IS ALL WE HEAR IS THAT
CRITICISM SITE MAYBE THERE'S
GOOD STUFF SO YEAH A AND AND I
THINK THAT'S OF IMPORTANT POINT
THE ONLY. POLL THAT THAT I'M
AWARE OF THAT'S BEEN CONDUCTED
ON THIS ISSUE ACTUALLY FOUND
THAT A MAJORITY PARENTS THOUGHT
THE DASHBOARD PRESENTED
INFORMATION AND HELPFUL MANNER.
IT WAS NOT A HUNDRED PERCENT WE
CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE THEIR AREAS
THAT THERE CAN BE IMPROVEMENT
BUT A LOT OF THAT INTO
IMPRESSIONS ARE INTERPRETATIONS
OF THE DASHBOARD OR HOW. DUMB
ARE BEING SHAPED BY WHAT
INDIVIDUAL ADVOCATE SOMETIMES
FEEL OR SORT OF YOU HOW
INDIVIDUAL PEOPLE REACT TO IT
WHICH ISN'T ALSO REPRESENT HOW
OF HOW ALL. SO I I THINK THAT
THAT THAT POLL FOUND THAT
ACTUALLY A YOU KNOW A MAJORITY
OF PARENTS THOUGHT IT THOUGHT IT
WAS PRESENTING INFORMATION AND
HELPFUL MANNER WHICH DOES NOT
SAY CAN'T BE IMPROVED COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH YOU. ON THAT BECAUSE
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER SOMEONE
COMING TO IT FRESH
CAN INTUITIVELY UNDERSTAND WHAT
THE INFORMATION IS BECAUSE AS
WE'VE I THINK ALL MENTIONED.
THIS IS REALLY DIFFERENT FROM
WHAT PEOPLE ARE USED TO WRITE
PAPER USED TO A SINGLE NUMBER
SAID IT'S A PART OF IT IS NO
MATTER WHAT YOU DO IS GOING TO
TAKE AWHILE FOR PEOPLE GET USED
TO WHAT WE'RE ACTUALLY. SERVE
WHAT MULTIPLE MEASURES ARE AND I
THINK THAT THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
THAT CAN BE DONE IN TERMS THAT
THAT IS ACTUALLY UNDER WAY. OF
LOOKING AT YOU KNOW.
HOW DO YOU THAT THE FOCUS WAS
HOW DO YOU GET THE RIGHT
INFORMATION IN THE WEBSITE I
THINK THIS IS? CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT WE'VEHEARD FROM OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH
SORT OF BIG YOUR DATA SYSTEM
REVIEWS AS YOU GOTTA. FIGURE OUT
THE RIGHT INFORMATION IS AND
THEN ONCE YOU DO THAT YOU REALLY
FOCUS ON THAT USER INTERFACE
EXPERIENCE. ANSWER THAT QUESTION
HOW DO WE IMPROVE THE DESIGN SO
THAT SOMEONE COMING THAT THERE'S
TOO MANY WORDS ON THE PAGE
THAT'S ONE VERY COMMON AREA
FEEDBACK. IF YOU NEED TO USE
WORDS TO EXPLAIN WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING THERE'S THINGS YOU CAN DO
WITH GRAPHICS AND OTHERWISE THAT
MAKE IT MORE INTUITIVE FOR
PEOPLE COMING TO THE WEBSITE. SO
I THINK THAT'S THE WORK AHEAD
I'M E. AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW
THERE'S REPOSE ON GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET FOR SOME ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT THE
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE DASHBOARD.
WE THINK THAT BE VERY HELPFUL TO
SUPPORT THIS WORK AND REALLY DO
YOU. KNOW USER TESTING DESIGN
WORK.
AS WE MOVE INTO THIS OUR NEXT
PHASE A VERIFYING THE DASHBOARD
SACRAMENTO FOR.
I'M CAN I GET INTO THIS THIS
WHOLE QUESTION OF.
AND THE EXTENT TO WHICH THE
FEDERAL TO THE FELLOW GARMENTS
ASK US TO.
IDENTIFY LOS FROM SCHOOLS.
INDIVIDUALLY.
BUT FOR OUR CITY COUNTY PURSES
WE'VE CHOSEN AND IF I DISTRICT
AS A WHOLE.
AND I I LOVE IT JUST TO HAVE YOU
RIFFLE OF IT ON THE ADVANTAGES
OF OUR APPROACH BUT AT THE SAME
TIME. POWER RECONCILING THIS
REQUEST FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
.
ON THAT QUESTION.
SURE SO THAT AS YOU MENTIONED
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA REQUIRES A DEDICATION OF
DISTRICTS THE EVERY STUDENT
SUCCEEDS ACTS REQUIRES THE
IDENTIFICATION OF SCHOOLS. AMENT
SPECIFICALLY UNDER ASCI IT'S THE
IDENTIFICATION OF THE LOWEST
PERFORMING FIVE PERCENT OF TITLE
ONE SCHOOLS.
AND SO. I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY
THAT INITIALLY BOTH THE CD AND
THE STATE BOARD HAD A DESIRE TO.
.
SOMEHOW MAKE OUR IDENTIFICATION
PROCESS UNDER LC FF FIT INTO.
WHAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WAS
REQUIRING UNDER ASSA?
AFTER SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THERE.
BUT.
INTERPRETATION OF START SHOOTING
FRANKLY I THINK IT'S FAIR I'M IS
THAT NO CALIFORNIA YOU CANNOT
IDENTIFY. SCHOOLS EXCUSE ME
CANNOT IN HIGH DISTRICTS YOU
HAVE TO GIVE US MISLEAD THE LIST
OF LOWEST PERFORMING SCHOOLS.
AND SO.
WE HAVE DEVELOPED A CRITERION
BASED.
PROCESS FOR THE IDENTIFICATION
OF THE SCHOOLS THAT'S
ARTICULATED IN THE DRAFT STATE
PLANTS OF THE STATE BOARD HAS
NOT YET APPROVED.
THIS PROCESS ALTHOUGH THE US
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION HAS
ESSENTIALLY SIGNED OFF ON IT AND
THE IDENTIFICATION WILL
ESSENTIALLY BEAM.
THAT IF YOU HAVE THE MAJORITY OF
YOUR INDICATORS ARE RED.
FOR YOUR SCHOOL THEN YOU WILL
BE IDENTIFIED AND THAT SORT OF
GOES UP FROM THERE WITH
ADDITIONAL CRITERIA BUT IF
YOU'RE PRIMARILY RED OR WRITE AN
ORANGE. THEN YOUR SCHOOL WILL BE
IDENTIFIED FOR THEM.
ASSISTANCE UNDER. AS YOU KNOW
THERE'S JUST ONE SCHOOL IN THE
LA A.
CAN A CUDGEL BEEN HERE THOUGH I
THINK I THINK THE REASON
CALIFORNIA HAD THAT APPROACH
ALTHOUGH I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
THAT AND IF I LOWEST PERFORMING
SCHOOLS. IS THE CAPACITY TO HELP
THOSE SCHOOLS SUCCEED HAS TO
HAPPEN AT THE DISTRICT LEVEL.
BECAUSE UNDER THE OLD NCLB AND I
LIVE THIS YOU HAD A CONSULTANT
FROM THE OUTSIDE COMING YEAR
SCHOOL NOT IN YOUR DISTRICT
OFFICE.
YEAH THEY WERE THERE FOR THREE
YEARS INTO YOU LIFTED YOU KNOW
YOUR YOUR SCORES UP AND THEN
THEY LEFT AND THE CAPACITY.
TO KEEP THAT GOING DID NOT
REMAIN AND I THINK THAT THE IDEA
HERE IS THAT THIS EXPERTISE HAS
TO BE DEVELOPED.
BUT THE DISTRICT LEVEL LIMIT
DOESN'T MEAN WE DON'T IDENTIFY
LOW BLOWS FOR SCHOOLS WITH A
GREAT QUESTION TO THEM BECAUSE
LET ME OUT SO LET ME ASK ABOUT
THIS I KNOW WE'RE GONNA BE
HEARING FROM THE AND THE FOLKS
FROM THE CONSORTIUM IN A LITTLE
BIT. BY.
ONE OF THE INTERESTING
CONVERSATIONS RIGHT NOW THAT
COMES DOWN TO WHETHER.
IT THE EXTENT TO WHICH DISTRICTS
GET TO ASK.
YOU'LL GET THE BASIC CHOOSE YOU
PROVIDE THEM WITH SUPPORT SO I
THINK THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
AND REQUIRES A SIX OR PER THEIR
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION FOR
SUPPORT.
BUT WE CREATED THIS
SEE SEE TO. ASSIST WITH JUST
THOSE KIND OF SITUATIONS I
THOUGHT SO WHAT WHERE WE.
WHAT WHAT'S WHAT'S THE STORY
HERE IN TERMS OF FUN WHEN?
QUESTION SO I I THINK WE WOULD
DEFERRED OF THE THIRD PANEL
WHICH IS FOR A. LEGISLATING
ALICE OFFICE AND PARTNER FINANCE
ON THEIR OF QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IF THAT'S
OKAY JUST BECAUSE I I KNOW THAT
THEY HAD THAT DEL WEEK THEY'LL
BE COVERING THAT BUT BUT I
THINK.
GOING BACK TO THE ISSUE OF
SCHOOL IDENTIFICATION HOUSE IT
FIT WITHIN A DISH AND UP YOU
KNOW. LOOKING TROUGH ANY FORMULA
FOCUSES ON LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCY AS THE LOCUS OF
RESPONSIBILITY FOR IMPROVING
CLASSROOMS I THINK.
TOOK TO THAT POINT THAT'S TRUE
BUT THERE'S NOTHING INCONSISTENT
WITH THAT ELLIOTT FOCUS TO SAY.
DISTRICT YOU NEED TO FOCUS ON
SCHOOL IS REALLY STRUGGLING
BECAUSE YOU MIGHT NOT BE AT THE
MOMENT OR AT LEAST WE'RE GONNA
ENSURE THAT IS PART OF THE
DISCUSSION IN DEVELOPING YOUR
LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN. YOU
ARE PAYING ATTENTION IF THE
SCHOOL THAT MAYBE YOUR OTHERWISE
HIGH FLYING DISTRICT BUT THERE'S
A SCHOOL THAT STRUGGLING.
I'M SO SO WE BELIEVE I I THINK
THE STAFF RECOMMENDATION TO
INCORPORATE THESE CHANGES IN THE
IN THE FEDERAL PLAN. WITH THE WE
DO NOT LEAVE THIS IS
FUNDAMENTALLY INCONSISTENT WITH
LCF AFTER AN ANYWAY BECAUSE THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT DISTRICTS
SHOULD BE DOING WE EXPECT
DISTRICTS TO BE LOOKING AT THEIR
SCHOOL LEVEL DATA. AND
RESPONDING APPROPRIATELY WITHIN
THE LOCAL ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN
PROCESS
IT'S A WE THINK THERE'S A WAY TO
GO ABOUT ADDRESSING THE SCHOOL
IDENTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS
UNDER ESTA UNDER THAT APPROACH
IN PARTICULAR. BECAUSE ASSN
ITSELF GIVES LEAD UP TO THE
STATE'S TO REALLY FIGURE OUT HOW
DO WE DO THAT SCHOOL IMPROVEMENT
PROCESS
SO THIS STATE WE CAN CHOOSE TO
BAKE IT MAKE IT VERY MUCH A
DISTRICT FOCUSED PROCESS I'M.
OKAY DO YOU THINK OR THE ANOTHER
THING ANOTHER CAME UP IN THE
CONTEXT OF THE THE FEDERAL
REVIEW.
HOW DID YOU WITH THE WAY THEY
WERE WAITING VARIOUS THINGS IN
THE CONTEXT OF OUR
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN SO AND?
IN A.
TEST SCORES IN GRADUATION RATES
VERSES SUSPENSION RATES IMPAIR
ENGAGEMENT. THEY WERE CONCERNED
THAT THERE WERE. SOME VERY
TANGIBLE ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE
MEASURES THAT WEREN'T GIVEN
ADEQUATE. WEIGHT.
I.
WHERE IS THAT CONVERSATION GOING
WITH THE FEDS?
SURE SO THE US THE STATUTE
REQUIRES THAT.
THE IN THERE ARE ACADEMIC
INDICATORS AND NON ACADEMIC
INDICATORS COURSE CALIFORNIA'S
PROPOSING TO HUMBLE.
UNDER S. A STATUTE ACADEMIC
INDICATORS HAVE TO HAVE.
THE WORD MUCH GREATER WEIGHT IN
THE AGGREGATE THANK YOU.
THAN NON ACADEMIC INDICATORS I
KNEW HE HAD.
AND SO PART OF THE CONVERSATION
WITH THE US DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WAS OKAY CALIFORNIA
FOR THE INDICATORS THE YOU HAVE
THEIR ACADEMIC AND NON ACADEMIC
HOW CAN WE ENSURE THAT IN THE
IDENTIFICATION OF SCHOOLS. THAT
I AM A SCHOOL ESSENTIALLY IN THE
EXAMPLE OF MAYBE THEY HAVE A
REALLY GOOD SUSPENSION RATES OF
THEIR A GREEN OR BLUE BUT ALL
ROUND ACADEMIC INDICATORS HOW
CAN WE ENSURE THAT THAT SCHOOL
DOESN'T BEASLEY ESCAPE
IDENTIFICATION. AND SO THE WAY
THAT WE'VE CREATED THE CRITERION
FOR IDENTIFICATION OF SCHOOLS
DOES NOT ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN.
IT DOESN'T.
A HIGH.
SO EVEN IF YOU'RE.
THE MAJORITY OF INDICATORS ARE
RED BUT ON A NON ACADEMIC
INDICATOR.
LIKE SUSPENSION RIGHT YOU'RE
DOING VERY WELL YOU WILL STILL
BE IDENTIFIED FOR.
ASSISTANCE UNDER ASSA.
THE SUIT IF IF OKAY SO EASIER
SINCE OKAY SO YOU'RE SAYING IS
THAT THERE'S A YEAR FEELING
CONFIDENT ABOUT.
A MECHANISM FOR.
ADEQUATE ATTENTION BEING GIVEN
TO. REAL TANGIBLE ACADEMIC
CHALLENGES.
I AM YES.
OKAY BLASTING ALASKAN AND MAYBE
THIS IS ALL MAY GO.
AUTHOR THIS OUT HERE FOR SOME OF
THE FUTURE PANELS TO BUT I KNOW
THERE SPEND.
HER BROAD CONCERNED IN SOME
OTHER STATES I'VE HEARD LESS
ABOUT HERE BUT WAY YOU KNOW I
READ ABOUT SOME OTHER STATES
THERE'S BEEN.
.
SERIOUS CLAIMS MADE ABOUT
DISTRICTS ENCOURAGING.
I LOWEST LOWER ACHIEVING
STUDENTS FROM. THEIR FOR STAYING
HOME ON TEST DAYS.
ESOS TO MAKE DO THE SCHOOLS
LOOK GOOD I'M THIS IS BETTER THE
REAL SCANDAL AND IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY. ARE AS THIS COME
UP IN YOUR CONVERSATIONS AND
AND.
MAYBE SOMETHING OUT I TALKED TO
THE.
NEXT COUPLE PANEL'S ABOUT.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT HOW AND.
BUT BUT BUT IT SINCE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ELIOT OUTCOMES IN
THE LOCAL LEVEL AND CAN YOU TALK
A LOT ABOUT. ANY WORK TO MAY BE
IN THAT SPACE.
LIKE I CAN SPEAK TO THE THERE
THERE IS A FEDERAL REQUIREMENT.
THAT WE THAT WE MEASURE AND
GIVE A RATE TO EVERY SCHOOL IN
EVERY DISTRICT AS TO THE
PARTICIPATION RATE AND AND THE
STATEWIDE ASSESSMENTS.
OUR PARTICIPATION RATE HAS BEEN
VERY HIGH SO THOSE KIND OF
ISSUES HAVE NOT. HAVE NOT REALLY
COME TO CALIFORNIA WHERE I THINK
WHERE OTHERS STATES HAVE
EXPERIENCED IT.
IS WHERE YOU HAVE A LARGE
AMOUNT OF THEM PERHAPS ANTI
TESTING OR ANTI COMMON CORE
SENTIMENT.
AND THEY'VE THEY'VE.
ENCOURAGED PARENTAL OUR DOUBTS.
FOR THAT AND SO IN SOME CASES
PERHAPS INCORRECTLY.
OUR PARTICIPATION RATE IS VERY
HIGH IN THE STATE AND THERE'S
VERY FEW EXAMPLES OF LARGE
NUMBERS ABOUT DOUBTS.
MCCARRON THANK YOU AND IT'S
INTERESTING ARE YOU WEBSITE I'M
SO SORRY WHAT WHEN ONE OF THE ON
ASK ABOUT HOW TO DO WITH.
THE BELLWETHER EDUCATION
PARTNERSHIP POURED THAT TALKED
ABOUT THE KIND DEEMED S. PRETTY
SIGNIFICANTLY ON.
AND THE CENTERS WERE GIVING
SCHOOLS IN THE SENATE TO IMPROVE
STUDENT PERFORMANCE.
DE DO YOU.
WHAT WHAT'S IT WHAT'S YOUR TAKE
ON THAT ISSUE?
I I GUESS I WOULD SAY THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF FACTUAL ERRORS IN
THEIR ANALYSIS THAT THAT WE END
UP RESPONDING TO THEIR TO MAKE
CORRECTIONS TO THEIR REPORT
BECAUSE THEY ACKNOWLEDGE THEY
MISS READ OR. OVERLOOKED CERTAIN
PARTS OF INCLUDING THE PLAN SO I
I THINK JUST IN TERMS OF.
WHETHER THAT IS A. THAT THE
QUALITY AND RIGOR OF THEIR
INTERVIEW PROCESS THEY WERE
WORKING THIS IS YOU KNOW
EVERYONE HAS TO TURN THIS AROUND
REALLY QUICK BECAUSE OF THE TIME
LINES AND REVIEWING PLANS IN
THESE ARE HUNDRED TWENTY SOME
PAGE DOCUMENTS. SO I THINK WHAT
WE WOULD DISAGREE WITH THE
CONCLUSIONS FROM A RESEARCH AND
LINGER PERSPECTIVE IN MANY
RESPECTS. BUT I THINK
FUNDAMENTALLY WE DISAGREE WITH
THEIR CONCLUSION WHICH IS THEIR
VIEW THAT THE ONLY WAY TO TAKE
SERIOUSLY SCHOOL IMPROVEMENT IS
TO GO BACK TO THE APPROACH TO
SCHOOL IMPROVEMENT UNDER NCLB
THAT WAS UNSUCCESSFUL.
AND THAT WAS REALLY THE LANDS
AND FRAME THEY WERE BRINGING TO
IT WE WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ENGAGE WITH THE STAFF FROM THEM
HE WORKED ON IT AND THAT BECAME
QUITE CLEAR IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS.
SO I THINK THEY JUST HAD US OR
PRE PRECONCEIVED NOTION OF WHAT
THEY BELIEVE A GOOD PLAN LOOKED
LIKE. IN CALIFORNIA'S INNOVATING
ARM AS CHAIR TALENTED DISCS THE
WERE THERE COUNTRIES WATCHING
WHAT CALIFORNIA'S DOING BECAUSE
IT IS. A DIFFERENT APPROACH TO
IMPROVEMENT.
AND I THINK THAT SORT OF OUR
OVERALL RESPONSE WOULD BE THAT
IF IT'S A.
IT'S A LITTLE IRONIC FOR PEOPLE
WHO WORK IN I THINK WERE ALRIGHT
WE FOCUS. ON THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
IN THE DISPARITIES THAT EXIST.
BUT THERE'S HAVE PERSISTED FOR
THE LAST TWO DECADES UNDER THE
APPROACH THAT BERMAN CRITICIZED
FOR NOT GOING BACK TO YOU. SO I
THINK WE WOULD PREFER TO YOU
KNOW TAKE THE TEN THAT WERE
ASKING DISTRICTS AND TEACHERS
THAT YOU'RE DOING SOMETHING
ISN'T WORKING FOR STUDENTS.
TO TRY SOMETHING DIFFERENT AND
SO I THINK THAT THAT'S WHAT WE
WOULD I THINK. YOU'D RATHER
INCENTIVIZE THEN DEMONIZED.
CAN THE DEMONIZING PATH DID NOT
WORK WE SAW THAT RIGHT FOR HOW
MANY YEARS THAT'S THE QUESTION
HOW BUT HOW MUCH ARE WE SENATE
RISING EFFECTIVELY.
WELL AS I I THINK WE CAN WE CAN
LOOK AT THAT AT SOME DATA POINTS
THAT SHOW THAT WERE ON THE RIGHT
TRACK WE SEEM THERE'S CLEARLY A
LOT OF WORK TO DO IF YOU LOOK AT
THE ASSESSMENT RESULTS AND I
THINK IT WE EVERYONE WOULD
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE'S. A LOT
OF WORK TO DO THERE TO IMPROVE.
YET TO SUPPORT THAT TEACHERS IN
CLASSROOMS HOW THEY'RE LIVING
INSTRUCTION. BUT YOU KNOW YOU
CAN LOOK AT GRADUATION RATES THE
HIGHEST IT'S EVER BEEN IT'S
ACTUALLY NARROWING GAPS IN
GRADUATION RATES HISTORICALLY WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST. NUMBER OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE GRADUATING
ELIGIBLE FOR UC AND CSU.
.
SUSPENSION RATE IS GOING DOWN
THERE IS A RECENT STUDY RELEASED
BY THE LEARNING POLICY INSTITUTE
THAT SHOW THAT ACTUALLY THE
DIFFERENTIAL INVESTMENTS THE
FUNDS. TO DISTRICTS UNDER LCF
AFTER THE SUPPLEMENTAL
CONCENTRATION GRANTS YOU
ACTUALLY SING GREATER
IMPROVEMENT ON MATH SCORES. IN
GRADUATION RATES AT DISTRICTS
ARE GETTING MORE OF THEIR STUFF
ON ON CONCENTRATION DOLLARS SO
THERE'S SOME EARLY EVIDENCE IS
CERTAINLY NOT CONCLUSIVE. I
THINK THAT'S WHY THERE'S A
COMMITMENT TO REALLY KEEP AN EYE
ON THIS AND LISTEN. TO DISTRICTS
STAKEHOLDERS AND OTHERS ABOUT
WHAT'S WORKING WHAT ISN'T AND
HOW WE CAN IMPROVE IT.
BUT TO SORT OF I THINK WE DO
HAVE EVIDENCE TO SHOW THAT WE
ARE ON THE RIGHT TRACK IT'S
EARLY OTHERS BUT WITH US IN THAT
WE CAN BUILD ON.
THANK YOU AND JUST JUST TO TRY
DIDN'T WANNA MAKE SURE THAT.
THAT CHAIR ALAN THAT YOU KNOW IN
A STUDENT ISN'T SHOWING TESTING
DAY THAT THEY'RE GONNA TAKE THE
TEST ANOTHER DAY. IS NOT ONLY
GIVEN ONE DAY SO THAT. THERE'S
SOME OTHER PLACES WHERE I WAS.
I MEAN THAT MAY BE TRUE BUT SO
THE STUDENTS SHAUNA MONEY
THERE'S TESTING ON MONDAY.
SCHOOL GUY CAPTURE THEM AT SOME
POINT AND GIVE THEM THE TEST SO
IT'S NOT JUST A YOU ARE HERE
THAT DAY IT INTO JUST NOT OF
PARENTS SIGNED A WAIVER. WHICH
IN MY EXPERIENCE.
PARENTS WERE SIGNING WAIVERS ARE
MORE ENGAGED AND THOSE WHO ARE
NOT.
THAT'S A DIFFERENT STORY THEN
THEY WOULDN'T TAKE THE TEST SO
THERE'S WAIVERS AND THERE'S JUST
MISSING THE TASK OF TWO
DIFFERENT THINGS I WOULD SAY.
AND THEN ON THE ON ON ON
SUBMITTING THE APPLICATION TO
THE FEDERAL LEVEL THAT'S.
THEN IT GOES BEFORE THE BOARD ON
THE TWELFTH.
AND YOU EXPECT TO BE BLESSED BY
THE BOARD AND THEN IT WOULD BE
MAILED OFF.
TO.
US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
PARTNERS EDUCATION.
AND.
AND DO YOU HAVE A TIME LINE
FOR WHEN YOU WOULD HEAR. WHETHER
IT SAY DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
TIMELINE WHERE WERE PASSED AT
THE TIME THAT THE US DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION HAS TO FORMALLY
REVIEW AND ACT ON OUR PLAN BUT.
BASED ON OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION I
AM I THINK NOT NAIVELY SO BUT
OPTIMISTIC THAT OUR PLAN WILL BE
APPROVED SHORTLY AFTER WE TURNED
IT IN. A MONTH.
SIX WEEKS THINK THAT SOMEWHERE
IN THE STONE JUST. RIGHT.
PROBABLY BEFORE SUMMER FISH.
ARE YOU REALLYHOPE THEY COME
ABOUT DOCTOR WEBER.
SORRY I WAS LATE AND I'M IN.
TOO MANY MEETINGS AND PROBABLY
AND ONE RIGHT NOW I UNDERSTAND
FROM MY STAFF BUT.
WANTED ASKS. YOU KNOW THE
DASHBOARD IS IS AS POINTED OUT
BY. A SENATOR HERE THAT HAS HAS
BEEN A REALLY.
DIFFICULT THING TO MANAGE IN
TERMS OF THE AVERAGE PARENTS I
MEAN I I THINK THE DATA. THAT WE
GET FROM THE DASHBOARD IS GREAT
FOR SCHOOLS BECAUSE SCHOOLS NOT
TO DEAL WITH DATA AND SO THIS IS
SOMETHING THEY'VE HAD ALL ALONG
BUT. BEING ABLE TO EAT BASICALLY
PUT IN THE PUBLIC FOR THE PUBLIC
TO CONSUME IT HAS BEEN A
CHALLENGE.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I FIND
PEOPLE CONSISTENTLY ASKING ABOUT
AND I AND I SOON ASSUME IT'S HIT
SOMEWHERE BECAUSE THEY MAKE
REFERENCE TO IT IN YOUR REPORT.
IS A COMPARATIVE DATA. YOU KNOW
OF PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY WANT
TO KNOW HOW DOES THIS SCHOOL
COMPARED TO ONE ACROSS THE
STREET.
YOU KNOW THEY MAY NOT BE AS
SOPHISTICATED AS AS THOSE WHO
HAVE ALL ACCESS TO THIS AND CAN
MANIPULATE THINGS THEY WANT TO
KNOW. IF I PUT MY KID ON THIS
SIDE OF THE STREET WHAT WILL BE
THE OUTCOME SOURCES ON THE OTHER
SIDE OF THE STREET. SO. ARE WE
PLANNING TO MAKE THAT KIND OF
COMPARATIVE DATA. A EASIER TO
ACCESS BECAUSE I KNOW YOU SEE
IT'S HE IT SOMEWHERE ON WOULD OF
FIVE BY FIVE OR SOME KIND OF A.
IS THAT TO BE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
DO IN IN THE IN THE DASHBOARD OF
THE PARENTS
SEEM TO LIKE EVEN INDICATORS
BLAH BLAH BLAH BLAH.
THE AVERAGE CREATE IS A REAL
SIMPLE LIFE THEY WANT TO KNOW
WHERE MY SCHOOLS FAN IN
COMPARISON TO OTHER SCHOOLS IN
THE DISTRICT I MEAN. YEAH. AND
MAYBE EVEN WANT TO KNOW NOT JUST
HOW DO I COMPARE TO THE SAME
SOCIAL ECONOMIC BECAUSE MOST OF
THEM WANT TO GET ABOVE A
SOCIOECONOMIC. SO THE QUESTION
IS ARE WE MAKING IT EASIER TO
ACCESS THAT KIND OF INFORMATION
ON THE DASHBOARD.
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR ANSWERING
THAT WAY THAT'S OKAY. FINE I'M
SYSTEMS WHERE THIS IS.
BACK BUT BUT YES WE ARE
ACTUALLY THAT'S ONE OF THE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WAS MADE
BETWEEN THE ORIGINAL FIELD TEST
OF THE DASHBOARD. I'M VERSUS THE
FALL RELEASE THE DASHBOARD IS
THERE'S NOW A REPORT. THAT IS
FOR EVERY DISTRICT I'VE ITS OF
ITS ON THE MAIN LANDING PAGES
ONE. CLERIC
TO GO TO BE ABLE TO SEE EVERY
SCHOOL IN THE DISTRICT.
WHAT COLOR THEY ARE ON ALL THE
INDICATORS RIGHT TOGETHER IN ONE
PLACE
SO YOU CAN ACTUALLY SEE AND
COMPARE THAT DATA WE'VE GOT
REQUESTS TO DO SOMETHING
SIMILAR?
AT THE COUNTY LEVEL SO YOU CAN
LOOK AT ALL THE EXPECT BETWEEN
NOW AND THE NEXT
ASH BOARD RELEASED IN THE FALL.
SO THAT'S PART OF ALSO OF WHAT
WOULD BE A PART OF THAT IS
WHETHER THAT LAY OUT THAT IS
CURRENTLY IN. WHICH IS MORE LIKE
YOU CAN SEE A ROW WITH NO TEST
SCORES FOR. ALL THE SCHOOLS
THINKING LIKE SORT IT WHETHER
THAT APPROACH WORKS IF THERE'S
ANOTHER APPROACH THAT WOULD BE
EASIER AND MORE ACCESSIBLE FOR
FOR PARENTS AND OTHER USERS NOW
YOU HAVE TO IDENTIFY THE WHAT
THE LOWEST FIVE PERCENT OF WHAT
IS IT SOMETHING LIKE THAT IS
THAT ALSO ON THE. DASHBOARD.
THAT GOAL BLESSED.
PENDING THE APPROVAL OF THE
BOARD WILL BE GENERATED IN THE
FALL OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND SO
THAT THE LESS HAS NOT YET BEEN
CREATIVELY WOULD BE VISIBLE ON
THE DASHBOARD FOR PARENTS TO
SAY.
YES THAT DECISION HAS NOT YET IS
NOT IN THE INFORMATIONAL BE
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE OKAY.
I KNOW WE'VE INCREASED OUR
GRADUATION RATE MED DATA IS
THERE ALL DO WE HAVE ANY
QUALITATIVE ANALYSIS A
DISCUSSION OF WHAT THAT REALLY
MEANS.
AND I SAY THAT BECAUSE I I GET
MEETINGS FROM MY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOLKS STILL TELL ME
DESPITE THE HIGH INCREASING
GRADUATION RATE. THE THE
REMEDIAL DATA THAT IS STILL IN
THE SEVENTY EIGHTY PERCENT OF
SOME COMMUTING CALLED JUST.
SO.
IN THEIR MIND SOMETIMES
GRADUATION ONLY MEANS YOU'VE.
STUFF BUT IT DOESN'T INDICATE
ANYTHING QUALITY I HAVE WE DONE
ANYTHING THAT MIGHT INDICATE.
THAT. THE GRADUATION INCREASING
GRADUATION RATE OR THE ACT OF
UP.
THE ATTAINING OF A HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA REALLY TRANSCENDS INTO
SOME KIND OF ACADEMIC.
ACCOMPLISHMENTS MORE THAN
ATTENDANCE ACCOMPLISHMENT.
SO I YES.
IT AND I THINK THAT CALIFORNIA
LED THE WAY NATIONALLY IN THIS
REGARD WHICH IS DEVELOPING A
COLLEGE CAREER INDICATOR.
WHICH WERE ACTUALLY GETTING THE
SECOND YEAR OF DATA WILL BE
AVAILABLE THIS FALL SO ACTUAL BE
ABLE TO PRODUCE A COLOR. ON THE
DASHBOARD TO SEE HOW YOU DOING.
THIS YEAR COMPARED TO LAST YEAR
IN THAT LOOKS AT THINGS YOU KNOW
RIGHT NOW IS HE SAID A DIPLOMACY
WHICH JUST SHOWS YOU MEMBERS
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS. BUT THIS
IS LOOKING AT A DIFFERENT
OPPORTUNITIES THAT STUDENTS
BASICALLY HAD.
THROUGH THEIR HIGH SCHOOL
EXPERIENCE IN IS THE RANGE OF
OPPORTUNITIES CAREER BASED AND
COLLEGE PREPARATION BASE SO IT'S
NOT AN INDIVIDUAL ON SENATE IS
AN INDIVIDUAL STUDENT MEASURE.
BUT IT'S LOOKING AT AT SCHOOL OR
DISTRICT LEVEL WHERE THE RANGE
OF PROGRAMS AND RICH OFFERINGS
THAT THEY HAVE TO PREPARE
STUDENTS FOR SUCCESS WHEN THEY
GRADUATE.
SO IT'S A IT'S MORE ROBUST
MEASURE WE BELIEVE.
AND I THINK THERE'S ADDITIONAL
DATA THAT'S GONNA BE
INCORPORATED INTO IT TO BUILD
OUT THE CAREER MEASURES WHICH AT
THIS POINT ARE A LITTLE LIMITED.
BUT IT IT IT IT GETS NOT NOT
AND NOT THE INDIVIDUAL STUDENT
LEVEL BUT IN TERMS OF.
PROGRAM EVALUATION THINKING
ABOUT OF ON THE DISTRICT LEADER.
ARE MY HIGH SCHOOL STRUCTURE TO
PREPARE STUDENTS FOR SUCCESS TO
PURSUE THE OPPORTUNITIES THAT
THEY WANT WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
INFORMATION IS A REALLY VALUABLE
BECAUSE IT'S. LASSEN TO LOOKING
ANALYZE.
CROSS THE DIFFERENT WAYS THAT
STUDENTS CAN. DEMONSTRATE THAT
THEY'RE READY FOR SUCCESS
HOW MANY WHICH ONES ARE STUDENTS
AT THIS SCHOOL. DEMONSTRATING
COMPARED TO OTHER SCHOOLS AND
WHAT TYPES OF OFFERINGS MIGHT WE
WANT TO BUILD UP THE SCHOOL TO
MAKE THAT UP.
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO OUR PANEL
DISCUSSION WELL DONE.
HELPED A CALL OF OUR NEXT PANEL.
WELL LET'S SEE INNOVATION AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY ALL SPEAK DOOM
OF FIRST IS THE ROLE OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BY GREG BLACHE
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE THERMAL
ITO.
UNION ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT
IF YOU COULD PLEASE COME FORWARD
THEN THE ROLE OF COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION THAT MISS JUDY
WHITE IS HERE. SUPERINTENDENT OF
RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
ALSO IS THE ROLE OF THE
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE OF
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE DOT
DOCTOR COURT CARL CONE IS
SOMEWHERE OUT THERE THERE IS.
GOOD GUY.
AND.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF IS USING
THESE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND
THEN CHELSEA SMITH A CONSULT
WITH A C. C. E. AND RON WILLIAMS
SUPERINTENDENT OF VICTOR VALLEY
UNION. HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND I BELIEVE WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH. MISTER BLAKE
SUPERINTENDENT BLAKE YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN READY.
WELL THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL AND CHAIRMAN ALAN IN
THE REST OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
HAVING ME HERE TODAY MY NAME'S
GREG BLACHE AND THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF THERMALLY TO
UNION ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
I DO WANT TO MENTION IT WITH ME
TODAY OUR TO.
TO THE ADVOCATES AND.
PEOPLE THAT HELP ME IN OUR
DISTRICT FROM BUTTE COUNTY
OFFICE OF ED A MICHELLE SANCHEZ
AND.
GENET SPENCER THERE ARE
INVALUABLE TO HELPING US DO OUR
DIFFERENT SHOULD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM AND.
LOST ALL OF THE OTHER THINGS
THAT WE DO THE COUNTY OFFICE.
WE HAVE A REALLY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH THEM.
I WAS.
TOLD THAT I HAD A LIMITED
AMOUNT OF TIME SO I ACTUALLY
WROTE DOWN WHAT I'M GONNA SAY
BECAUSE I WANT TO KEEP IT
CONCISE.
SO I'M JUST GONNA READ IT TO YOU
THAT'S OKAY.
ALRIGHT.
SO.
SO I'M HERE TO LET YOU KNOW A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THEIR LEGAL
UNION ELEMENTARY SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND WHERE WE HAVE TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN THROUGH EIGHTH
GRADE.
THE STUDENT POPULATION OF ONE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
FIVE TOTAL STUDENTS IS NINETY
TWO PERCENT ON DUPLICATED.
.
THE DISTRICT S. BACK DATA
INDICATES TWENTY PERCENT MET OR
EXCEEDED GRADE LEVEL
EXPECTATIONS AND MATH AND TWENTY
SIX PERCENT NEIL A AND WEBER
PRESCHOOL THREE T. K. THROUGH
FIVE ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS ONE
SIXTH THROUGH EIGHTH GRADE
MIDDLE SCHOOL IN A COMMUNITY DAY
SCHOOL.
SO I'M HERE TO.
ALSO TALK ABOUT DIFFERENTIATED
ASSISTANCE THE PROCESS AND HOW
THAT MODEL WORKS AND YOU COUNTY.
SO LET ME BEGIN BY TELLING YOU
THAT THE RELATIONSHIP WITH EACH
DISTRICT HAS WITH THE BEAT
COUNTY OFFICE ABED IS UNIQUE.
BUT WE ALL WORK TOGETHER AND
MAYBE A LITTLE DIFFERENT AND
BICU COUNTY. SO ONE OF SPEAK
WITH OTHER SUPERINTENDENTS
AROUND CALIFORNIA I'M SURPRISED
AT HOW LITTLE THEY KNOW. THE
OTHER SUPERINTENDENTS IN THEIR
COUNTY.
AND HOW LITTLE THEY ACCESS EACH
OTHER IS RESOURCES.
SO IF I'VE EVER HAVE AN ISSUE OR
NEED SOME SUPPORT I KNOW THAT MY
FELLOW SUPERINTENDENTS WILL GIVE
ME THE GUIDANCE TO WORK IT OUT
AND I FEEL FORTUNATE.
TO LIVE AND WORK AND YOU COUNTY.
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD
IS VALUABLE IN IDENTIFYING AREAS
OF NEED OF GROSS OR OR
IMPROVEMENT.
WHICH HAD A LONG DISCUSSION
ABOUT WILL I CONSIDER LONG LONG
DISCUSSION ABOUT ON THE DASH
WERE JUST MY FEW MINUTES AGO.
AND SO FOR INSTANCE ARE CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM DATA FOR TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN TO
SIXTEEN PERCENT. WHICH IS KINDA
HIGH AND THEN ALSO WAS A FOUR
PERCENT INCREASE FROM THE
PREVIOUS YEAR.
THIS IS NOT EXPECTED BY TO GIVE
US INFORMATION TO CHALLENGE OUR
CURRENT THOUGHTS REALLY DIVE IN
DEEP. INTO WHY OUR KIDS ARE
MISSING SCHOOL AND.
ONE OF THE GENTLEMEN HERE
EARLIER SAID THAT WAS SOMETHING
THAT THE DASCHLE THIS MOST FOR
EXACTLY WHAT THAT IS FORCE WE
CAN SEE THAT INDICATOR. AND
REALIZE WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THIS PROBLEM IS VERY
SPECIFICALLY.
SO MANY OF OUR FAMILIES.
IN OUR COMMUNITY SUFFER FROM
INTERGENERATIONAL.
POVERTY AND EXPERIENCE CHRONIC
STRESS IN MEETING THEIR DAILY
NEEDS. AND SO TO ADDRESS CHRONIC
ABSENTEEISM AND SOME OF THE
OTHER SOCIAL EMOTIONAL NEEDS OF
OUR STUDENTS ARE STAFF.
IS CAN BE TRAINED BY BCO WE STAB
YOU COUNTY OFFICE OF ITS WERE
USING COUNTY RESOURCES.
THAT'S PART OF A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT AND COLLABORATIVE.
.
A RELATIONSHIP THAT WE HAVE SOUL
BE LEARNING ABOUT ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES TRUMP
INFORM SCHOOLS TO GAIN AN
AWARENESS OF HOW OUR STUDENTS
ARE AFFECTED BY VARIOUS FORMS OF
TRAUMA.
ON THIS LOBBY HAPPENING IN THE
FALL.
UNFORTUNATELY WE WE ALSO HAVE AN
AWARENESS OF UNIQUE KINDS OF
TRAUMA AND STRESSORS IN OUR AREA
WITH THE RECENT FIRES.
THEIR LOSSES OF HOMES AND PETS
AND THEN ALSO THE OROVILLE DAM
SPILLWAY FAILURE IN THE
SUBSEQUENT EVACUATIONS.
AND THAT'S ALL HIT OUR KIDS
HARDWARE FAMILIES HARD.
SO RESEARCH IS CLEAR THAT IF WE
GROW THE CAPACITY TO ENGAGE IN
CONNECT OUR STAFF WITH OUR
STUDENTS THROUGH THESE TRAINING
STUDENTS WILL BE LIKE MORE LIKE
TO COME TO SCHOOL. IF THEY COME
TO SCHOOL WILL BE MORE
SUCCESSFUL IF IT WERE SUCCESSFUL
THEY'LL FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE IN
FROM WORK AND COMFORTABLE TO
COME TO SCHOOL. SO IT'S A CIRCLE
WHO JUST TRYING TO GET THESE
KIDS HERE.
SOLAR OR ABOUT THE DASHBOARD.
MAR TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN A
DASHBOARD DISPLAY THAT OVERALL
E. LA LITERACY PERFORMANCE FOR
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES. HAD
DECLINED SIGNIFICANTLY WAS RED
TALK ABOUT THE COLORS SO WE HAD
A RED. A RED DOT.
FOR TWO YEARS IN A ROW IN THAT
SAME STUDENT GROUP HAD
SUSPENSION RATES THAT WERE ALSO
READ AND THAT'S WHAT PUT.
THOSE ARE THE INDICATORS THAT
PUT US IN A DIFFERENTIATED
ASSISTANCE.
SO.
WORKING WITH COUNTY OFFICE WE'RE
ABLE TO.
.
LOOK AT OUR.
OUR SITUATION AND ALSO WE HAD
ALREADY IDENTIFIED ARE
SUBSTANTIAL IN ANOMALIES WHEN
REPORTED IN OUR CAL PASSED OUT
IN THE SPRING. AND WE HAD
IMPLEMENTED PROCEDURES AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS SCHOOL YEAR
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN.
TO IMPROVE OUR SUSPENSION RATES
DISTRICT WIDE.
.
SO OUR STUDENTS HAVE
TRADITIONALLY BEEN PERFORMING.
THAT LOW LEVELS ON E. L. EN
MASSE STANDARDIZED TESTS FOR
YEARS SO. WITH THE SUSPENSION
RATES WE ALSO NOTICE THESE THE
WE'RE LOOKING AT THOSE RED DOTS
WE WE SEE HOW LONG THEY'VE BEEN
PERFORMING AT THIS LEVEL AND
IT'S JUST. IT'S JUST DROWNED TO
SOMETHING WE NEED TO IMPROVE SO
IN THE SPRING OF LAST YEAR WE
BET BEGAN TO STRATEGIZE HOW WE
CAN HELP OUR STUDENTS ACADEMIC
POOR PERFORMANCE.
WE BEGAN TO WORK A PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING COMMUNITIES.
SOLUTION TREE CONSULTANTS.
AS OUR CAPACITY IN PLC'S GREW
WE MADE A DISTRICT COMMITMENT
THIS YEAR TO HONOR COLLABORATION
TIMING USE AGAIN CONSULTANTS
FROM OUR COUNTY OFFICE TO
FACILITATE GRADE LEVEL TEAMS.
TO REACH.
THE OUTCOMES THAT WE DECIDED ARE
IMPORTANT FOR OUR STUDENTS.
SO DURING THESE GRADE LEVEL
COLLABORATIVE MEETINGS WE ALSO
DISCUSSED IN FOUNDED EARLY THE
NURSERY WAS AN AREA FOR GROWTH
AND WEAK CONTRACTED AGAIN WITH
OUTSIDE EXPERTS A BUTTE COUNTY
PEOPLE. TO FACILITATE STAFF
TRAININGS IN EARLY LITERACY IN
READING TEACHING STRATEGIES.
NUMBER FOCUS.
WHAT WITHOUT BACKGROUND
INFORMATION ON FOCUS A LITTLE
BIT ON WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE?
SO.
OUR THE ORIGINAL PLAN WITH YOU
COUNTY OFFICE OF THAT WAS TO
PROVIDE EACH ELLIE EIGHTEEN THAT
OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME FAMILIAR
WITH EXISTING DISTRICTS SYSTEMS
IS WHAT THE COUNTY WAS DOING.
PARTICIPATE IN ROOT CAUSE
ANALYSIS AND DEVELOP CLEAR
PROTOCOLS FOR MOVING FORWARD.
SO THIS PROCESS WORKED WELL FOR
TO THE FOR.
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE
DISTRICTS A BUTTE COUNTY.
THEY WERE FAIRLY THOSE.
PARTICULAR DISTRICTS WERE FAIRLY
NEW ADMINISTRATIVE TEAMS AND
THEY BENEFIT FROM.
THE SIGNIFICANT BACKGROUND
INFORMATION ITSELF EVALUATION.
MY DISTRICT THERMAL ITO HAD
ALREADY WORKED THROUGH MUCH OF
THAT.
MUCH OF THE SELF EVALUATION AND
ALREADY IMPLEMENTED INITIATIVES
TO IMPROVE STUDENT. ACHIEVEMENT
ATTENDANCE AND STUDENT
CONNECTEDNESS.
SO THIS IS THE BEAUTY PART OF
HAVING OUR COUNTY OFFICES
WORKING WITH THE SO CLOSELY. IN
THE SPIRIT OF DIFFERENTIATED
ASSISTANCE
THE COUNTY OFFICE WAS NIMBLE
ENOUGH TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE ARE
TO HAVE STRONG INITIATIVES IN
PLACE.
AND WE NEEDED SOMETIME IN A BIT
OF SUPPORT TO EVALUATE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF OUR WORK BUT WE
DIDN'T HAVE TO BE.
CONFORMED INTO A ROUND PEG INTO
A SQUARE HOLE MINUTE THAT'S THE
BEAUTY PART OF THIS
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE. WITH
THE COUNTY.
THEY UNDERSTOOD. ON THAT WE HAD
SOMETHING PROVEN AND WE WERE
GONNA HELP OUR STUDENTS.
SO THE PROCESS THAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH A VIEW COUNTIES NOT
PUNITIVE AT ALL.
IT'S BECAUSE IT PERHAPS IT'S
BECAUSE WE ALL REALLY KNOW EACH
OTHER.
IT'S THAT SHE'S TRULY THE
COUNTY OFFICE WORKING ALONGSIDE
US TO IMPROVE STUDENT LOAN OR
LEARNING FOR ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS.
THE COUNTY OFFICE OF IT DOESN'T
PROHIBIT US FROM TRYING NEW
THINGS TO HELP OUR. HELP OUR
STUDENTS BECAUSE ULTIMATELY IN
OUR COUNTY THEY'RE ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS.
SO.
.
FROM THAT PERSPECTIVE AND BEING.
A MEDIUM SIZE DISTRICT IN OUR
COUNTY OUR LARGEST SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS ABOUT IS ABOUT TEN
THOUSAND AND OUR SMALLEST
DISTRICT I THINK IS IN THE EIGHT
RANGE.
EIGHT TOTAL STUDENTS IN THE
DISTRICT SO.
WEEK WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT KIND OF COMMUNITY UP
THERE.
AND BEFORE I GOT THIS JOB AT IT
AT A DISTRICT OF FIFTEEN
HUNDRED.
I WAS IN A VERY SMALL DISTRICT
OF NINETY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT SO
WE HAD ABOUT A HUNDRED KIDS
NINETY FIVE EIGHTY AND I WAS A
SUPERINTENDENT AND PRINCIPLE.
AMONG OTHER THINGS.
SO I ASK FOR COUNTY SUPPORT A
LOT WHEN I WAS THERE AND THEY
THEY WERE ABLE TO GIVE US A LOT
OF SUPPORT UP THERE.
.
AND THEY PROVIDED A PROGRAMMATIC
ANALYSIS.
RIGHT NOW THE COUNTY OFFICES
WORKING WITH THAT GROUP.
IT THAT THIS. THE PERSON UP
THERE THIS YEAR I'M GONNA TELL
YOU THIS IS THERE'S ABOUT EIGHTY
FIVE KIDS HE SUPERINTENDENT IS
PRINCIPLE AND HE TEACHES MATHS
FOR EIGHTH GRADE.
SO I MEAN HE IS A BUSY GUY
ENEMIES OF THE THESE ARE THE
SITUATIONS THAT WEWORK WITH UP
THERE ON AND IN IMPLEMENTING
THESE KINDS OF INITIATIVES I
MEAN CAN JUST. BREAK BECAUSE WE
TALK ABOUT THE.
THE PROCESS OF DIFFERENTIATED
ASSISTANCE IN THE PROCESS OF
THAT WE HAVE TO GO THROUGH I
FEEL VERY FORTUNATE THAT.
OUR COUNTY IS ABLE TO HELP US
INDIVIDUALLY.
AND WITH THIS YOU CAN UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE OF BEING A OF WHAT I
CONSIDER A MICRO SCHOOL DISTRICT
BECAUSE IT'S HARDLY EVEN SMALL.
.
I WANT TO ASK YOU TO CONSIDER A
FEW THINGS YOU'RE LOOKING
FORWARD I KNOW THAT YOU WILL BE
HELPING MAKE DECISIONS IN THE
FUTURE AND AYE I JUST ASK YOU
CAN CONSIDER A FEW THINGS.
I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE AN
ENORMOUS RESPONSIBILITY AND MUST
TRY TO BALANCE THE NEEDS AND
EXPECTATIONS OF STAKEHOLDERS OF.
A DISTRICT THE SIZE OF LA
UNIFIED.
WHICH IS ROUGHLY TWO AND A HALF
TIMES THE POPULATION OF BUTTE
COUNTY THAT A LITTLE BIT OF
RESEARCH SUGGEST LA UNIFIED
TWENTY HAVE TIMES ARE HOPE
COUNTY.
POPULATION THAT BLOWS MY MIND.
I CAN HARDLY IMAGINE THE CHOIR
OF VOICES THAT SEEM TO YOU ALL
THE SAME TIME AND WHAT NOISE
THAT MUST SOUND LIKE.
BUT ASK YOU CONSIDER
REGULATIONS OUR FUTURE CHANGES.
ON THAT YOU CONSIDER THE AMOUNT
OF STAFF AND RESOURCES THAT
THESE MICRODISTILLERIES HAVE.
SO GIVE ME A QUICK EXAMPLE I
BELIEVE THAT. I BELIEVE THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY IS IMPORTANT.
WE NOW HAVE THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA.
I DON'T WANT TO GO BACK TO ANY
SORT CATEGORY OLD COLD NONSENSE.
I AGREE THAT WE MUST BE
TRANSPARENT WHEN DECISIONS ARE
BEING MADE.
SO THE SOMETHING LIKE. THAT
HERE'S A SUGGESTION RATHER THAN
ASK IS SUPER IMPRINTS
SUPERINTENDENT PRINCIPLE SLASH
TEACHER TO CONSTRUCT A NINETY
PAGE EL CAP.
WITH THE SAME FORMATTING
REQUIREMENTS AS THOSE OF A
DISTRICT THAT HAS A TEAM OF
PEOPLE TO DO THE SAME THING.
PERHAPS IT'S THE COUNTY OFFICES
THE GROUP THAT APPROVES THE EL
CAP.
COULDN'T THEY WORK TOGETHER TO
CRAFT A MODIFIED VERSION OF THAT
THAT MAKES MORE SENSE TO A SMALL
COMMUNITY. AND SOMETHING MAYBE
MAKE IT SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY
PEOPLE.
WILL READ AND USE.
I GET CONCERNED WHEN WE PROVIDE
A NINETY FIVE PAYS LIKE WE'RE
TALKING NOW THE DASH WORKS
CONFUSING YOU PUT IT EL CAP IN
FRONT OF A PARENT. THEY THIS
THEY GLAZE OVER THEY CAN'T THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT THEY'RE
LOOKING AT SO. I MEAN LET'S I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TINY DISTRICTS AND
AND AND EVEN BIG DISTRICTS ARE
ONLY TALK ABOUT. THESE KINDS OF
THINGS IT'S IMPORTANT TO.
ENGAGE.
THE COUNTY OFFICES AND A
PROVIDING LOCAL CONTROL OF THE
TO THE DISTRICTS TO FOCUS ON
WHAT THEIR UNIQUE NEEDS ARE.
AND I THINK THAT HELPS US.
SO MANY CLOSE BY TELLING YOU
THAT I'M OPTIMISTIC ABOUT
EDUCATION CALIFORNIA AND I'M
DELIGHTED ABOUT THE CHANGES THAT
MY DISTRICT IS MAKING TO IMPROVE
STUDENT OUTCOMES ARE REALLY AND
WE'RE WE'RE. KILLING IT RIGHT
NOW.
I'M EAGER TO GET STARTED ON OUR
A MULTI TIERED SYSTEMS OF
SUPPORT OUR MTS ES GRANT THAT
WE'RE WRITING RIGHT NOW AND I
APPRECIATE THAT. MY PRINCIPLES
CAN TAKE PART IN TRAININGS LIKE
THE PRINCIPLES LEADING
LEADERSHIP NETWORK WHICH IS
SPONSORED BY THE C. C. E.. WE
DON'T HAVE THOSE KIND OF
OPPORTUNITIES A LOT OF THEIR.
THESE ARE EXCITING TIMES IN
EDUCATION AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME AND WILLINGNESS TO LISTEN
TO A GUY THAT'S IN THE TRENCHES.
LOVE MY.
MY WRITTEN SPEECH THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME I APPRECIATE IT
REALLY.
DO APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU.
WELL SO THAT'S THE PERSPECTIVE.
FROM ME DISTRICT WORKING WITH
COUNTIES YES.
WHEN I'M HERE PERSPECTIVE FROM
COUNTIES.
WE'VE GOT YOU A SUPERINTENDENT
OF THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION.
LOVE TO HEAR YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON
ALL THIS OKAY FIRST OF ALL AYE
SENATOR ALLEN THAT AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
AT STAFF I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE
YOU TODAY.
I SERVE AS A RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT. WOULD START ON
FEBRUARY TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
WE HAVE TWENTY THREE DISTRICTS
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS.
AND WE HAVE A VERY CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP WITH ALL OF OUR
SUPERINTENDENTS MEETING WITH
THEM ON A REGULAR BASIS.
AND DISCUSSING BEST PRACTICES.
I WANT TO ON TALK ABOUT MY
PERSPECTIVE UNDER THE LENS OF
DOCTOR LARRY BESIDES QUOTE. THAT
SAYS WE MUST PURSUE LEARNING FOR
ALL. NOT BECAUSE IT IS
POLITICALLY EXPEDIENT BUT
BECAUSE THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS
AN EXPENDABLE CHILD.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT REALLY
DRIVES SAYS TO ALWAYS TRY TO
FIND A SYSTEM THAT WILL HELP
EACH AND EVERY CHILD.
SO TODAY YOU'VE ASKED ME TO
PROVIDE MY PERSPECTIVE AS A
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
ON HOW THE STATE'S EVOLVING
SYSTEM OF ACCOUNTABILITY. AND
SUPPORT IS WORKING.
AS YOU KNOW COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT THE. OFFICE OF
EDUCATION PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE
IN THIS SYSTEM. AND WE TAKE THAT
RESPONSIBILITY VERY SERIOUSLY.
BUT AS COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT BY
BILL THAT I HAVE AN EVEN GREATER
RESPONSIBILITY. TO ENSURE THAT
ALL RIVERSIDE COUNTY SCHOOLS
SERVE THEIR STUDENTS WELL. AND
PREPARE THEM FOR EVERY STAGE OF
THEIR LIFE.
I PERSONALLY FEEL THAT THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM HELPS ARE YOU
TO UNDERSTAND THEMSELVES AND
OTHERS AND POSITIONS THEM FOR
BREAKING THE CYCLES OF POVERTY.
AND TO CONTRIBUTE TO SOCIETY IN
THE MOST POSITIVE WAITS.
THIS IS MY FORTY FIRST YEAR IN
THE FIELD OF EDUCATION.
AND I TRULY BELIEVE THAT EVERY
STEP ON MY JOURNEY AS A TEACHER
PRINCIPAL LOCAL SCHOOL
SUPERINTENDENT DURING THAT TIME
WHERE. THE LC UP THAT WAS
IMPLEMENTED HAS PREPARED ME. FOR
THIS RESPONSIBILITY.
IT IS STILL THE BEST LENDS UP
RESPONSIBILITY THAT I HAVE
CONSIDERED YOUR QUESTION.
THERE ARE NO SHORT ANSWERS IN
THE EDUCATION BUSINESS BUT MY
SHORT ANSWER IS THAT THE SYSTEM
IS WORKING. BUT REMAINS A WORK
IN PROGRESS.
WE'VE SEEN SOME ENORMOUS CHANGES
IN THE FIVE YEARS SINCE GOVERNOR
BROWN SIGNED THE ORIGINAL HOUSE
YET THEM. LEGISLATION AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY WE ARE BEGINNING TO
SEE PROGRESS IN IMPROVING
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
SINCE THE ENACTMENT OF LC UP
THAT OUR OUR SEAL  TEAM HAS
USE EXISTING STRUCTURES. AND
NETWORKS TO LAY THE GROUNDWORK
FOR UNDERSTANDING THE NEW
SYSTEM.
WE MAKE GREAT EFFORTS TO ENSURE
THAT A CONSISTENT MESSAGE IS
HEARD AT ALL LEVELS.
SUPERINTENDENTS INSTRUCTIONAL
LEADERS FISCAL TEAMS WHO THAT
ARE NOT DIRECTORS PRINCIPLES ARE
FAMILY ENGAGEMENT AND CHARTER
SCHOOLS NETWORKS AND MANY
OTHERS.
WE'VE WORKED HARD TO BUILD OUR
INTERNAL CAPACITY TO UNDERSTAND
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD
AND ARE GRATEFUL TO THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS ASSOCIATION TO
SUFFER. FOR THEIR VARIETY OF
RESOURCES AND PRESENTATION
TOOLS.
THEY HAVE DEVELOPED FOR COUNTY
OFFICES TO ENSURE A CONSISTENT
MESSAGE IS HEARD THROUGHOUT THE
STATE SO AFTER WE MEET WITH ALL
OF THESE GROUPS WE KEEP MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAD THE SAME
MESSAGE TO EACH GROUP. AT
SUPPORT.
TO PROVIDE YOU WITH JUST ONE
EXAMPLE OF OUR WORK WE HAVE
ENGAGE WITH SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
SCHOOL SITES THAT. AND POUND
LEADERS IN CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE COMPONENTS
OF THE DASHBOARD. AND HOW THE
DASHBOARD CAN'T SUPPORT THEM TO
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT AREAS WHERE
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
GROWTH.
ONE THING WE HAVE TO EMPHASIZE
STRONGLY IN ALL OF OUR
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS.
IS THAT THE DASHBOARD DISPLAYS
OUTCOMES AND NOT THAT PRACTICES
ACTIONS TO SERVICES THAT A
DISTRICT IS IMPLEMENTING.
I STAFF DISCUSSES WITH OUR
SCHOOL LEADERS LOCAL MEASURES
AND INDICATED THAT THEY CAN
MONITOR FREQUENTLY. TO ENABLE
TIMELY ADJUSTMENTS AND OF COURSE
CORRECTIONS IN A PROACTIVE
MANNER.
OUR APPROACH IN THESE EFFORTS IS
TO EMPHASIZE REFLECTIVE INQUIRY
INTO THEIR DASHBOARD DATA.
WE KNOW THAT THE COUNTY OFFICE
DOESN'T ALWAYS KNOW ALL THE
ANSWERS AND MANY OF THE BEST
ACTORS COME FROM OUR DISTRICTS
BUT WE DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
SUPPORT. THIS TYPE OF REFLECTIVE
INQUIRY.
I SHARE ALL OF THIS WITH YOU
BECAUSE I THINK IT REPRESENTS A
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
OUR CURRENT ACCOUNTABILITY
SYSTEM. AND WHAT USED TO EXIST
NCLB AND OTHER PREVIOUS
STRUCTURES.
BEFORE SOMEONE FROM THE COUNTY
PAPPAS MIGHT GO INTO A DISPUTE
WITH THE BINDER OF STRATEGIES
THAT THE DISTRICT LEADERS HAD TO
CHOOSE BROWN. WITH NO GUARANTEE
THAT THOSE STRATEGIES WOULD MOVE
THE BALL FORWARD ON STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT.
NOW WE ENTER INTO THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR DISTRICT
COLLEAGUES AS THOUGHT PARTNERS.
AND EXAMINE THE DASHBOARD DATA
TOGETHER IN SEARCH OF ROOT
CAUSES.
SO WE WERE DIRECTED TO BEAT UP
TO MAKE SURE WE IN THAT WITH.
ALL OF THE SUPERINTENDENTS.
WHO FELLOW TO DIFFERENTIATE
ASSISTANCE PROJECT TO THE WINTER
BREAK AND THEN WE HAD SUBSEQUENT
MEETINGS WHERE OUR TEAM WENT OUT
AND MET WITH THE? AYE IDENTIFY
PEOPLE THAT THE SUPERINTENDENT
TO BE ABLE TO SIT DOWN AND LOOK
AT THE LOG DATA NOW THIS IS THE
THIRD LEVEL WHERE WHERE THERE.
ARE SITTING DOWN AND DECIDING ON
WHAT WAS GOING TO BE THE
APPROACH SO IT'S BEEN VERY
ACTIVE AS BEEN ONGOING.
ONE GOING.
WE USE DATA ASSN INC RETOOL THAT
THESE TO DEEPER INVESTIGATIONS
SUGGEST QUESTIONS RELATED TO
OUTCOME GAPS IN VARIATION OF
STUDENT PERFORMANCE BETWEEN
SITES.
FOR EXAMPLE WHEN WE ARE
DISCUSSING OUR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES WE KNOW THAT THE
STUDENTS THEMSELVES ARE NOT
CAUSING THE PROBLEM BUT RATHER
THAT THERE ARE SIX ESTIMATE
ISSUES AND HOW THE STUDENTS. ARE
BEING SERVED TO RESOLVE THOSE
ISSUES SOMEONE NEEDS TO BE IN
THE CONVERSATION. BOTH FROM THE
COUNTY OFFICE AND THE DISTRICT
FROM THE EDUCATIONAL SERVICES
DEPARTMENT FROM THE STUDENT
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
DEPARTMENT.
WHICH FOCUSES ON STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES AND IN ALL
LIKELIHOOD SOMEONE FROM THE
SOUTHPAW. ONLY THEN CAN WE
INSURE THAT THERE IS A CLARITY
OF PURPOSE AND A COMMON GOAL SO
AS A COUNTY OFFICE WHAT WE CHOSE
TO DO IS NOT ONLY JUST LOOK AT
THE AGGREGATE. OF STUDENTS WITH
ON.
WITHOUT SPECIAL NEEDS WE LOOKED
AT THEIR DISABILITY SO WE
ACTUALLY WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE
FOR THE INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
HOW THEY WERE DOING BY EACH
INDIVIDUAL DISABILITY HOW WELL
ARE YOUR STUDENTS WITH AUTISM
DOING HOW WELL I THE STUDENT
WITH? OUR EMOTIONAL DID OUR.
NEEDS DOING AND THEY WERE ABLE
TO COMPARE DISTRICT WIDE COUNTY
WIDE AND THEN SHARE SOME BEST
PRACTICES BETWEEN. THE DIFFERENT
PART DISTRICTS SO WE WE ARE
MODELING THE CLAP THEIR APPROACH
AS.
AT OUR SEAL  COMPLAINING OF
FREQUENT MEETINGS ACROSS
DIVISIONS IN ORDER TO DISCUSS
HOW WE CAN PROVIDE A LINE
SUPPORT. BASED ON DISTRICT
NEEDS.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO SPEND SOME TIME
TALKING ABOUT WHAT WE CALL LEVEL
TWO DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE
WHICH. COUNTIES ARE NAPA BITING
AS PART OF THEIR STATUTORY ROLE
UNDER LCF AT. AND AGAIN WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO SO FACT FOR WORKING
WITH ALL THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENTS. TO ENSURE A
COMMON APPROACH TO PROVIDING
THIS ASSISTANCE.
AS BACKGROUND WE HAVE PROVIDED
YOU WITH THREE DOCUMENTS YOU
HAVE THREE ADDITIONAL DOCUMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN PROVIDED FOR YOU.
FROM OUGHT TO SHOW YOU HOW ARE
CO YOU HAS ORGANIZED ITSELF TO
DO THIS WORK.
WE CANNOT LEAVE IT TO CHANCE
WHAT WE MUST DO HAS TO BE
DELIBERATE AND HAS TO BE
INTENTIONAL.
SO THE DOCUMENT WILL ILLUSTRATE
THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN LEVEL
ONE ASSISTANCE AND ADDITIONAL
WORK WE ARE NOW ENGAGED IN AS
PART OF LEVEL TWO ASSISTANTS.
THE THIRD DOCUMENT IS A FLOW
CHART THAT ILLUSTRATES EACH STEP
IN THE PROCESS OF LEVEL TWO
ASSISTANCE.
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF POINTS
ABOUT THESE DOCUMENTS I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE ONE WE HAVE BEEN
VERY MINDFUL ABOUT ORGANIZING
OUR DIVISIONS IN THE COUNTY
OFFICE. THAT HAVE RESPONSIBILITY
FOR EDUCATIONAL SERVICES MEMBER
SERVICES PUT STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES IN A WAY THAT
CONTINUALLY COMMUNICATES HOW WE
CAN BE. OF SERVICE TO RIVERSIDE
COUNTY DISTRICTS
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT EDUCATORS
UNDERSTAND HOW. ALL THE PIECES
OF THIS PUZZLE THE DAX POURED
THE AL CAPP THE ANNUAL PDATE
AND DISTRICT BUDGETS ALL FIT
TOGETHER.
SECOND FOR THE DISTRICTS
ELIGIBLE FOR LEVEL TWO
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE WORD
TAKE IT WE ARE TAKING OUR
SUPPORT TO AN ENTIRELY NEW
LEVEL.
AND AS I TALK TO YOU ABOUT YOU
TO YOUR READY ABOUT JUST
AGGREGATING THE DATA.
IN LEVEL TWO SUPPORT WE ALSO
INVESTIGATE WHETHER DISTRICTS
ARE PARTICIPATING IN OTHER
INITIATIVE AND THAT WORKS TO
IMPROVE STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT.
SUBJECT DEVELOPING MULTI TIERED
SYSTEMS OF SUPPORT OR
PARTICIPATING IN THE
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING NETWORK
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
COLLABORATIVE FOR EDUCATIONAL
EXCELLENCE.
WE ALSO TRY TO LINE UP SUPPORT
WITH OTHER SPECIFIC
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEMS SUCH AS
THE ANA PERFORMANCE INDICATORS
INDICATOR REVIEW REQUIRED BY THE
A. FOR OUR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES.
I THINK YOU WILL BE ABLE TO SEE
A NUMBER OF RECURRING THEMES AND
ALL THIS WORK.
COLLABORATION.
ALIGNMENT.
BREAKING DOWN SILOS AND LASTLY
CLARITY OF PURPOSE MAKING SURE
THAT THE RIGHT PEOPLE ARE ON THE
SAME PAGE WITH RESPECT TO WHAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE.
AND WHEN THOSE TASK NEEDS TO BE
COMPLETED. TO SUMMARIZE THERE IS
A LOT GOING ON AND THERE ARE A
LOT OF MOVING PARTS IN THE
PROCESS.
AND EVEN THOUGH WE ARE BLESSED
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY TO BE ABLE
TO DEVOTE A LEVEL OF RESOURCE TO
TO THIS WORK THAT I THINK
COUNTIES MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
MATCH BECAUSE EACH COUNTIES.
UNIQUE FUNDING POSITION.
CAPACITY IS AN ISSUE WE HAVE TO
CONSIDER.
THAT ARE STILL E. WE ARE ALREADY
AT THE POINT IN HAVING TO.
TRIAGE OUR EFFORTS AND MAKE SOME
VERY DIFFICULT CHOICES AND
DECISIONS ABOUT WHERE TO FOCUS
THE WORK.
UNFORTUNATELY. WHEN THAT HAPPENS
IT WHEN IT OCCURS THERE ARE
STUDENTS WHO.
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN
MAYBE AT THE RISK FOR NOT.
RECEIVING THE LEVEL OF SUPPORT
THEY NEED TO IN ORDER TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
IN CONCLUSION WE HAVE A WAY TO
GO BEFORE WE GET DECLARE
SIXPACK.
BUT I TRULY BELIEVE THAT WE ARE
ALL ON THE RIGHT TRACK.
ONE OF THE. CURSES OF EDUCATION
IN CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN THAT WE
TO OPT IN CHANGE HORSES IN
MIDSTREAM AD DOT WELL MEANING
STRATEGIES AND WHAT I'LL CALL.
COURSE CORRECTIONS WHICH IN FACT
END UP TAKING US FURTHER AWAY
FROM OUR INTENDED DESTINATION.
MY OWN PERSONAL GOAL FOR
RIVERSIDE COUNTY IS THAT WE
ACHIEVE IN NINETY FIVE PERCENT
COUNTY GRADUATION RATE BY TWENTY
TWENTY AND THAT ALL OF THOSE
STUDENTS GRADUATE FULLY PREPARED
TO BE SUCCESSFUL. AND THE NEXT
STEP OF THEIR LIVES WITH THE
SKILLS TO BE THOUGHTFUL CARING
HUMAN BEINGS I DID I DO BELIEVE
THAT THE SYSTEM WE NOW HAVE IN
PLACE. IS THE BEST VEHICLE TO
GET US THERE.
THANK YOU.
GREAT THANK YOU. I KNOW HERE
FROM OUR DOCTOR CARL CONE IS A
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE TEAM
THANK YOU VERY.
THANK YOU ARM.
THE COLLABORATIVE. WE WEAR THESE
LITTLE WRISTBANDS AT SAY CC
THE RIGHT KIND OF HELP
WHICH ACKNOWLEDGES WHAT YOU ALL
HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT. THAT
THEIR WAS OUT THERE THE WRONG
KIND OF HEALTH PROBABLY FOR A
DECADE AND A HALF.
WE SEE OURSELVES AS THE HOLDERS
OF THE ONE TRUE RELIGION.
OF CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT AND
BUILDING CAPACITY IN ORDER TO
GET BETTER AS A COHEN I WOULD
EXPECT THAT.
I.
HAVE MY WITH OR I WOULD JUST
REMIND EVERYONE.
THAT.
BEFORE.
THERE WAS AN API AND BEFORE
THERE WAS A DASHBOARD.
THERE WERE SOME DISTRICTS
THAT WERE ACTUALLY GETTING
BETTER.
AND I SERVED AS SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS. AND ONE OF THOSE
DISTRICTS AND WE GOT BETTER
BECAUSE WE OWNED THE
ACCOUNTABILITY PROCESS.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. WE DIDN'T
SPEND A LOT OF TIME LOOKING AT.
STATE AND FEDERAL INDICATORS WE
SAID HAVE LONG BEACH IS GOING
GET BETTER. THEN WE BETTER ROLL
UP OUR SLEEVES AND WE BETTER OWN
THE ACCOUNTABILITY PROCESS AND I
WOULD ARGUE.
WE SHOULDN'T SPEND A LOT OF
TIME.
DEBATING DASHBOARD VERSES EIGHT
PI THE MESSAGE THAT WE'RE TAKING
OUT THERE IS THAT YOU GET BETTER
BY YOU HAVE THE KIDS YOU GET
BETTER. BY USING THE DATA TO
IDENTIFY WHO ARE THE MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS.
IN YOUR DISTRACT WHAT IS THE
DATA TELL YOU. ABOUT THAT AND
WHAT KINDS OF SUPPORTS
DO YOU NEED TO PUT IN PLACE
IN ORDER FOR THOSE YOUNGSTERS TO
BE BETTER SERVED.
WE HAVE ELEVEN PILOT
PARTNERSHIPS WE HAVE FIFTY SIX
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING NETWORKS
THOSE.
P. OUTLANDS ARE REACHING THREE
HUNDRED DISTRICTS APPRECIATE
SUPERINTENDENT BLAKE'S.
REMARKS ABOUT.
ON RPL LAN.
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE LOOK AT WHAT'S ACTUALLY
HAPPENING. ON THE GROUND WHAT
DOES THIS LOOK LIKE TO A REAL
DISTRICT IN REAL TIME AND SO
WITH US TODAY. SUPERINTENDENT
RON WILLIAMS OF THE VICTOR
VALLEY UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND OUR CONSULTANT
CHELSEA KANG THEY'RE THE TEAM
THAT CAN TALK ABOUT. WHAT CC
WORK ACTUALLY LOOKS LIKE?
IN A REAL DISTRICT.
BIRCH.
A GOOD AFTERNOON OF MONEY IN THE
STOCK TWO ONE WILLIAMS TYING
SUPERINTENDENT FOR THE BALLOT
UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT IT'S
BEEN MY PLEASURE TO BE A PART OF
THIS PILOT THROUGH THING.
INCEPTION OBVIOUSLY ARE COUNTY
OFFICE WITH A PART OF THIS
PROCESS.
BUT I'LL TELL YOU JUST WORKING
WITH CHELSEA IN FACT ONE OF THE
STORIES THAT I ONCE SAID TO HER
IF I WAS ASKING IF SHE WAS. IF
SHE WAS ON OUR PAYROLL BECAUSE
SHE WAS IN OUR DISTRICT FELT
OFTEN PROVIDING THE TECHNICAL
SUPPORT THAT I THINK IT WAS
INSTRUMENTAL. IN OUR SUCCESS.
WE'RE VERY UNIQUE DISTRICT WE
HAVE. ONE OF OUR SCHOOLS IS THE
HIGHEST PERFORMING HIGH SCHOOLS
IN THE COUNTY AND WE HAVE OTHER
SCHOOLS THAT ARE HALF AN
ACADEMIC CHALLENGES AND I THINK
THAT'S A CONTRIBUTING FACTOR TO
WHY. WE'RE GETTING THAT
DIFFERENTIATE ASSISTANT.
THROUGH THE COUNTY SUPPORT
WE'RE VERY VERY FORTUNATE TO
HAVE AN EXCELLENT COUNTY OFFICE
OF SUPERINTENDENT.
DIVISION THAT'S WORKING WITH US
BUT I'LL TELL YOU FROM BEING A
PART OF THIS PILOT FROM THE
BEGINNING. THE SUPPORT THAT'S
BEEN PROVIDED TO US BY C. C. E.
E..
HAS BEEN SECOND TO NONE NOW I
CAN'T SAY THAT THERE'S A CHELSEA
IN EVERY COUNTY. OF OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA BUT I CAN'T SPEAK
FOR OUR THAT OUR DISTRICT IN
PARTICULAR.
CHIEF THE FIXTURE. WITH OUR
TEACHERS.
OUR ADMINISTRATORS ARE SCHOOL
BOARD EXAGGERATE IT MAKES A BIG
BIG DIFFERENCE WHEN YOU HAVE
THAT ON THE GROUND SUPPORT THAT
EXPERT TEETH THAT I THINK THAT
YOU CAN ONLY GET BY TAKING WHAT.
EACH ONE OF OUR DISTRICTS ARE
DIFFERENT WOULD HAVE UNIQUE
NEEDS IN OUR PARTICULAR CASE I
KNOW THAT CC  HAS COME IN
WORK WITH US I THOUGHT PARTNERS.
TO LOOK AT THE.
THREE AREAS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT IF OUR SUSPENSION WAIT.
SPECIAL LATEST ENCROACHING ON
MOST SIGNIFICANTLY OUR
GRADUATION THIS WELL AS OUR MATH
SCORES IF THE AREAS THAT WE'RE
FOCUSING ON IN A CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT PROCESS.
WE'VE TAKEN OUR STRATEGIC PLAN
ARE AL CAPP IN OUR SINGLES
PLAYERS FOR STUDENTS EXCEPT IN A
LINE ALL OF THOSE. UTILIZING
NUMBER OF STRATEGIES THAT HAS
BEEN SHARED WITH THAT FORM OF.
I THINK THE E. SO I'M GONNA LET
HER SAY IF. MAKE A FEW POINTS
AND THEY WILL ADDRESS QUESTIONS
SUCH MAY HAVE.
TOM IT'S BEEN A JOURNEY AND OUT
RUNS GIVING ME WAY TOO MUCH
CREDIT.
YES I'M THERE BUT AT ITS RON
AND HIS TEAM AND ITS PRINCIPALS
AND TEACHERS THAT ARE DOING THE
WORK.
SO I NEED TO GIVE THEM HUGE
CREDIT AND RON ESPECIALLY.
WE STARTED OFF THE JOURNEY WITH
SEE SEE WHAT'S DIFFERENT ABOUT
THE SUPPORT AND ASSISTANCE THAT
CC PROVIDES. IS THAT WE HAD NOT
ONLY BILL CAPACITY.
AMONGST OUR LEADERS AND WE
STARTED THIS PATH OF HAVING FIVE
TWO DAY SUMMIT PER SCHOOL YEAR.
AT THE BEGINNING OUR
SUPERINTENDENTS THE LEADS OF THE
DISTRICT WERE INVITED. AND
THAT'S IN ORDER TO BUILD
CAPACITY AND TO ASSIST IN
WHICHEVER WAY THEY.
WITH LIKE FOR US TO ASSIST.
AND THEN THAT WE HAD LIKE A
PIVOTAL TURN I BELIEVE IN
OCTOBER SUMMIT. WHERE WE REALLY
DIVE INTO THE CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT PROCESS AND WE
LOOKED OUT ALL DIFFERENT MODELS
AND WE ALLOW?
OUR PILOT DISTRICTS YOU CHOOSE
THE MODEL AND AT THAT SUMMIT THE
MOST KEY IN PORN I BELIEVE.
.
ASPECT WAS THAT IT WASN'T JUST
THE SUPERINTENDENT THAT WAS FAIR
IT WITH THIS TEAM. SO HE BROUGHT
IN HIS ASSISTANT SUPERINTENDENT
DIRECTOR WHO OVERSEES EL CAP HIS
PRINCIPAL AND HIS ART TEACHER.
AS WELL AS E. L. BECAUSE WE ARE
ALSO LOOKING AT E. L. FOCUS.
SO IT WAS A COLLABORATIVE GROUP
A OF VICTOR VALLEY OF LEADERS
COMING TOGETHER.
TO WORK ON VICTOR VALLEY SAY
WASN'T US THE SUPERINTENDENT
ALONG WHICH MADE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE AND THEN AT THAT
SETTING. DATE DECIDED ON OKAY
WE'RE GONNA STICK TO THE PLAN TO
STUDY AT.
IMPROVEMENT MODEL AND FROM
THERE OF THE PRINCIPLE FROM
ATALANTA HIGH SCHOOL SHE DID A
FABULOUS JOB AFTERWARDS COMING
BACK. TO OF THE DISTRICT AND
SHARING.
WHAT WE'VE JUST LEARNED SEC'S
SUMMIT TO THE PRINCIPLES?
AND THEN OF RONALD SO THOUGHT
YOU KNOW WHAT THIS ALSO CONTINUE
OUR.
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT TEAM
WORK AND NEEDS MORE THAN JUST AT
THE SUMMIT.
SO THEN WE MET UP.
AFTER THAT I BELIEVE TWICE AND
EXPAND THAT THE GROUP TO EVEN
MORE AND YOU MAY ASK WELL WHY
WOULD YOU EVEN CONSIDER
EXPANDING AND IT'S BECAUSE.
JUANITA HAVE MORE IMPACTS AND
EFFECTS
AND A ONE OF THE STORY IS TOM.
A THE TEACHER FROM ADELANTO HIGH
SCHOOL THAT WAS PART THAT'S PART
OF OUR SUMMIT A TERRY BLACK SHE
TEACHES SPECIAL EDUCATION AND
SHE'S THE DEPARTMENT CHAIR. AND
SO WITH OUR CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT MODEL SHE WAS VERY
EXCITED. ON AND SAID THAT I'M
GOING TO TAKE IT BACK.
TWO I ALL MY DEPARTMENT AND GO
THROUGH THE CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT MODEL WITH MY
DEPARTMENT AND SEE WHAT WE COME
UP WITH.
SO OUR FOCUS AND OUR AND I'VE TO
SHARE WITH YOU THE FOCUS WAS A
JOURNEY IN A SELF.
BECAUSE LAST YEAR THE BIG BOMB
GLARING.
FOCUS WAS ON MATH
BECAUSE THE SCORES WERE SOLO.
AND THEN WE SHIFTED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE SCHOOL YEAR
INTO INCLUDING E. L..
AND THEN AFTER THE RELEASE OF
THE FALL THE DECEMBER DASH BOARD
OKAY YOU KNOW WHAT THE
SUSPENSION RATING GRADUATION
INCLUDED.
IT WITHIN THE SUBGROUPS.
SO THEN IT EXPANDED BUT THEN
ALONG WITH THAT EXPANSION ON IT
WAS GREAT TIMING IN THAT.
THE YEARS STRATEGIC PLANNING.
A WHOLE DIFFERENT GROUPS OF
COMMUNITY MEMBERS INCLUDED.
MET UP AND ALSO REVIEWED DATA
AND LOOKED AT THE CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT MODEL AND THE
DISTRICT'S FOCUS. AND THEN THE
SINGLE PLAN FOR STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT SO IT ALL CAME
TOGETHER. AND I LOVE THE FACT
THAT THE TEACHER IS TAKING A
BACK AND SAYING THIS IS AN
IMPROVEMENT MODEL THAT I COULD
USE WITH MY TEACHERS AT MY SIDE.
AND WORK ON IMPROVEMENT WITH OUR
STUDENTS SO THAT WAS EXCITING.
GREAT THANK YOU.
WITHOUT ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FOR THE PANEL I HAVE ONE.
WITH REGARD TO.
THE LOCAL DISTRICTS WHAT WHAT
ROLE DOES THE.
THE SCHOOL BOARD PLAY.
WELL OUR SCHOOL BOARD IS A PART
OF OUR STRATEGIC PLAN AS WELL AS
OUR EL CAP AND AS AT AND THE
SCHOOL BOARD WE UPDATE THEM IN
REGARDS TO I MEAN.
C. C. E. E. HAS COME AND PRESENT
TO OUR SCHOOL BOARDS ARE SCHOOL
BOY IT'S A VERY VERY AWARE OF
WHAT WE'RE DOING STRATEGICALLY.
AS WE'RE DEVELOPING AS WE'RE
EXPANDING THAT CONTINUES AND
CALL PROVE BUT POT PROCESS IN
THEY HAVE INPUT IN THAT PROCESS
AS WELL WE HAVE SOME OF OUR
BOARD MEMBERS TO COME TO EL CAP
MEETING THINK THAT YOU'RE.
AND THEN AS FAR AS I CLOUT
INSIDE THE CLASSROOM.
HOW IN THE WEEDS YOU GET?
I WOULD YOU GO TO THE CLASSROOM
SEE SEE WOULD YOU GO TO THE
CLASSROOM A BUCKET. OF THE TYPES
OF INSTRUCTION THAT ARE GOING ON
AND MAYBE SAY HEY YOU KNOW MAYBE
WE OUGHT TO BE YOU KNOW. DURING
THIS TIME OF THE DAY WE HAD BEEN
DOING MORE DIRECT INSTRUCTION.
MAYBE DURING THIS TIME OF DAY WE
NOT ONLY ANOTHER METHOD CAN YOU
WALK ME THROUGH WHAT DO WE TALK
ABOUT. YOU KNOW WHERE THE RUBBER
MEETS THE ROAD INSIDE THE
CLASSROOM. WHERE MIGHT THAT
CHANGE ME WHAT MIGHT YOU SEE?
THROUGH YOUR EXPERIENCE.
I THINK WHEN AND HOW.
A.
THE THREE OF US HAVE WALKED DOWN
CLASSROOMS TOGETHER.
BUT I HAVE TO BE HONEST WITH
YOU WE DON'T GO INTO CLASS WITH
AN EVALUATIVE LANDS WE GO INTO
THE CLASSROOM OF REALLY LEARNING
WHERE THEY ARE AT RIGHT NOW AND
THEN FROM THERE.
WILL COULD HELP.
AND IF THERE'S A NEED.
SO TO GIVE YOU LIKE A.
HIGHLIGHT OF A HUGE SPOTLIGHT
ON A WE VISIT A I BELIEVE IT WAS
LIKE THREE. WAS IT THREE OR FOUR
SCHOOLS BEFORE THE BOARD
PRESENTATION.
AND.
FROM THAT A IT WAS SHARED WITH
US THAT WE SHOULD REALLY GO AND
VISIT A ANOTHER HIGH SCHOOL
VICTOR VALLEY HIGH SCHOOL IT WAS
ONE OF THE VISITATIONS THAT WE
DIDN'T DO. THAT THEY HAD REALLY
PROGRESSED WELL AND THEIR CT
PATHWAY. SO THEN.
KARL AND MYSELF ALONE MADE
ANOTHER VISIT OUT THE VICTOR
VALLEY AND IT WAS JUST A
WONDERFUL VISIT.
VICTOR VALLEY HIGH SCHOOL JUST
TO SHARE WITH YOU DEEP.
C. T. PATHWAY GRANT HAS ALLOWED
THE DISTRICT TO REALLY BRING ON.
CAREER OF A REALITY TO OUR
STUDENTS
WHERE IN TALKING TO THE STUDENTS
AND TO THE TEACHERS.
THAT ARE TEACHING THE PROGRAMS.
VICTOR VALLEY STUDENTS ONCE
THEY COMPLETE THEIR CAPSTONE.
AND COMPLETE THEIR PATHWAY
THEY'RE ABLE TO FIND JOBS RIGHT
AWAY BEFOREGETTING ANY FURTHER.
EDUCATION AT ALL.
ON NOT THAT THEY WOULD STOP IN
THEIR EDUCATION PROGRESS BUT
THAT'S ONE OF THEIR OPTIONS THAT
THE NOW HALF WHICH IS HUGE.
AND I THINK MAYBE CARL YOU WANT
TO SHARE WITH A ABOUT THE
CULINARY.
SURE YEAH YEAH I AM EVERY NOW
AND THEN YOU KNOW YOU READ.
DAN WALTERS COLUMN THAT TALKS
ABOUT HOW. MOCHA ADS BEEN
TOTALLY ABANDONED IN THE STATE
THAT KIND OF THING.
A KIND OF A A MEDIA DRIVEN KIND
OF THING THE MAZING.
CULINARY ARTS.
GRAPHIC CARDS COMPUTER CODING.
THE CULINARY ARTS.
KIDS HAVE A PARTNERSHIP.
WITH THE.
THE LOCAL HOMELESS SHELTER
THERE PROVIDING MEALS THEY FEED.
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED FAMILIES AT
THANKSGIVING IN ADDITION TO OUR
INDUSTRY STANDARDS WHERE THEY
HAVE STATE OF THE ART PA
EQUIPMENT THAT SORT OF THING
IT'S VERY VERY IMPRESSIVE.
AN OVERALL COMMENT.
.
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL.
WITH REGARD TO CLASSROOMS
THIS-ISN'T SPECIFIC TO VICTOR
VALLEY.
ONE OF THE THINGS AS WE MOVE
AROUND THE STATE THAT WE SEE A
LOT OF.
IS.
IT'S ALMOST THE NOTION THAT.
.
PUTTING. A DEVICE IN FRONT OF
EVERY YOUNGSTER IS GOOD ENOUGH.
AND AND I THINK WE NEED TO DO
MORE IN TERMS OF THEIR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
THE TYPE OF TEACHER TRAINING
RETRAINING THAT NEEDS TO GO
ALONG WITH THAT IT'S NOT JUST
PUTTING A DEVICE IN FRONT OF THE
CHURCH KID. AND NOT PAYING
ATTENTION TO THE IMPORTANT
QUALITIES OF WHAT THAT TEACHER
BRINGS TO THE EQUATION.
GREAT LA CAN I ASK MY QUESTION
MAY BE A LITTLE DIFFERENT WAY
WITH. WITH HOW YOU PERCEIVE YOUR
OR HOW YOU VALUE IN ENGAGING
YOUR ROLE. IN IN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE STATE MAYES
FROM.
DR COHN MAYBE SOMEBODY WHOSE
JOB OFFER THEIR THEIR THEIR
OPINION OR.
OR EXPERIENCE.
I'M KINDA LOOKING AT AS YOU WALK
INTO A SCHOOL DOES HE KNOW
THERE'S PROBLEMS THERE. I ASSUME
YOU MEAN THE SCHOOL BOARD FIRST
I DON'T KNOW SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
.
SO.
THIS USELESS TAKE AN IMAGINARY
DISTRICT HOW OUT THAT IF THERE%
WAS AN IMAGINARY DISTRICT OUT
THERE LET'S JUST SAY THE
SUPERINTENDENT WASN'T
PERFORMING.
AND AND OR YOU SAW
ADMINISTRATORS AT THE SCHOOL
SITE NOT PERFORMING THAT OFTEN
CAN LEAD TO SOME OTHER THINGS
GOING ON AT THE CAMPUS OF THE
DON'T HAVE A.
YOU KNOW A A STRONG LEADER THERE
WE KNOW THAT THROUGH OUR OWN
EXPERIENCE SO WHAT. I'M KIND OF
LOOKING AT IT YOU KNOW HOW DO
YOU INTERACT WITH THE MANAGEMENT
HOW YOU ADDRESSES ISSUES. WHICH
MAY ALSO IMPACT HOW HOW HOW
THINGS ARE TAUGHT WHAT'S GOING
ON IN THE SERVICE YEAH I MEAN WE
WILL HAVE.
CONFIDENTIAL CONVERSATIONS WITH
OUR SUPERINTENDENTS AT SORT OF
THING.
HAVEN'T DONE IN VICTOR VALLEY
BUT IN ALMOST ALL OF THE OTHER
PLACES WHERE WE'RE WORKING.
I'VE PERSONALLY BEEN INVOLVED IN
THE BOARD GOVERNANCE TRAINING.
AND.
.
DOING IT IN LA UNIFIED ALL THESE
OTHER PLACES AND. WHAT WE FIND
OUT GOVERNANCE IS A HUGE
CHALLENGE?
AROUND THE STATE.
SOMETIMES.
WE ASSOCIATED THE LARGER
URBAN'S I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY
BECAUSE THE MEDIA COVERS THE
LARGER BANDS ON A DAILY BASIS
BUT BUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
GOVERNANCE.
SHOULDN'T BE UNDERESTIMATED ON
WE'VE HAD SITUATIONS IN PLACES A
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING IN WHERE
THE SUPERINTENDENT HAS HAS LEFT
ON. AND PART OF THAT WAS AN HOUR
SAYING ANYTHING ABOUT
PERFORMANCE IT WAS ABOUT.
CONVERSATIONS WITH BULL WORD
WHERE YOU ACTUALLY GET TO IS
THIS THE RIGHT FIT. IS THIS
GOING FORWARD THE WAY IT SHOULD
THAT SORT OF THING BUT WE DON'T.
WE DON'T COME IN AND SAY YOU GOT
BAD PRINCIPLES YOU GOT A BAD SU.
HE BETTER DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
BUT IF YOU SEE THAT.
WITH THE CAPACITY YOU'RE
BUILDING WITHIN THE ORGANIZATION
UNNATURAL IMPACT MIGHT BE THERE
SOME.
SOME CHANGE RIGHT.
CORRECT.
OTHER QUESTIONS.
YEAH I I'M I'M SO INTRIGUED BY.
THE WORK ON YOUR SERVE ACT
ALMOST LIKE CONSULTANTS TO.
SCHOOL DISTRICT I SUPPOSE.
I IS THEIR SON.
IS THERE A AYE WHAT AYE AYES YOU
GUYS YOU GO OUT AND DO ALL THIS
WORK ALL OVER THE STATE AND AND
AND IN TURN IMPROVE OUTCOMES ARE
THERE SOME THINGS THAT WE OUGHT
TO BE THINKING ABOUT SYSTEM WIDE
SOME LOW HANGING FRUITS AND.
BEST PRACTICES AND SPECIAL SAUCE
THAT YOU'VE.
BEEN ABLE TO EMPLOY EFFECTIVELY
TO TURN AROUND SOME SCHOOLS THAT
THAT WE OUGHT TO BE THINKING
ABOUT IT IN OUR POSITIONS.
YEAH I.
ONE MOMENT AGO THIS IS GOING TO
FINANCE A ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
KNOW AND I'M.
I LIKE IT'S ITSELF BUT FEE FI
.
AT OUR PRINCIPALS MEETING.
THINK THE HE'S THE STRATEGIES
THAT WE'VE DEPLOYED DOING THE
WORKSHOPS THAT'S BEEN APART OUR
BOARD MEETINGS.
OUR STRATEGIC PLANNING MEETINGS
ARE EL CAP MEETINGS.
THIS IS BECOME A FABRIC OF WHAT
WE DO THE PART OF OUR PLAYING
FIELD EVERYTHING THAT WE DO A
LOT OF THE STRATEGIES THAT WE
HAVE THERE. SO IF YOU'RE TALKING
TO OUR BOARD MEMBERS OUR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS ARE TEACHERS
ARE ADMINISTRATORS. THE WEALTHY
IN ALL OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS ARE
AWARE OF THE STRATEGIES THAT WE
UTILIZE TO CC AND I THINK THAT
FROM A. SYSTEM WIDE PERSPECTIVE.
IF THAT CAN BE INTEGRATED.
SYSTEMATICALLY IN COLLABORATIVE
THE WALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS.
I'M TALKING ABOUT THE BOARD THE
ADMINISTRATORS TO TEACHERS TO
CLASSIFIED CENTER. I THINK THAT
YOU CAN HAVE A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT BROUGH SOUNDS LIKE IT
SOUNDS LIKE.
AND I I HAVEN'T BEEN THERE IN
YOUR DISTRICT BUT.
I'M BUT. IT'S ALMOST AS THOUGH
YOU'RE SUGGESTING IT THERE'S AN
URGENCY ASSOCIATED WITH THE CC
IN THEIR THEIR.
PARTLY THERE BECAUSE THEY WERE
CHALLENGES.
THEY'RE PAYING CLOSE ATTENTION
EVERYONE FEELS THIS KIND OF.
SENSE THAT YOU KNOW THEY'RE PART
OF THIS PROJECT IN THEIRS
ENGAGEMENT FROM THE STATE IN.
I WILL NO I WOULD SAY THAT.
THERE IS AN URGENCY YET BUT IT'S
NOT DRIVEN FROM A MANDATED CC
PROCESS OBVIOUSLY THE
DISTRICT IS GOING TO HAVE TO
WANT TO CHANGE THEMSELVES.
IF THERE'S GOING TO MAKE THAT
IMPACT THAT YOU KNOW JUST
BECAUSE YOU HAPPEN OUTSIDE
FOURTH.
THAT'S THEY'RE SAYING SOMETHING
THAT YOU MAY NEED TO DO I THINK
FOR DISTRICTS THAT. TAKE THAT
APPROACH THEN.
THAT CHANGE WILL ONLY BE THERE
AS LONG AS THAT OUTSIDE
PRESSURES HERE BUT I THINK FOR
THOSE DISTRICT IT REALLY WANT TO
MAKE THE CHANGE THAT THEY NEED
TO IMPROVE. THE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR STUDENTS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
DOES CHANGE YOU ANYTIME YOU
LOOKED CHANGING THE CULTURE OF
AN ORGANIZATION IS PROBABLY ONE
OF THE MOST CHALLENGES THAT ANY
LEADER TAKES ON.
AND I THINK THAT WHEN YOU CAN
INSTITUTED AND HAVE.
LOOK BACK PROCESSES TO CHECK TO
SEE IF THIS IS REALLY HAVING THE
IMPACT IF INTENDED THEN YOU
COULD HAVE A MUCH MORE.
IMPACTFUL.
IMPACT ON WHATEVER GOES THAT
YOU'RE LOOKING TOWARD.
MILLIMETERS AB BED ON THE REASON
WHY I THINK RON'S MENTIONED ALL
THE DIFFERENT ASPECTS WARY C. C.
E. E. HAS BEEN PART OF IS
BECAUSE OF RON'S LEADERSHIP. IN
BEING VERY OPEN AND BELIEVING IN
THE PROCESS OF CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT.
AND.
.
I KNOWS
THERE WERE A LOT OF MENTIONING
OF THE WHERE THOUGHT PARTNER AND
WE WHERE THOUGH RESPECT. BY TO
TO RE OF RIGHT KIND OF HELP.
.
A MY ROLE.
CHANGES A LOT
AND THEN I JUST LIKE WHEN YOU
SHARED ABOUT LIKE THE EVALUATIVE
PIECE WHERE IF YOU DO NOTICE
THERE NEEDS TO BE. SOME AREAS
THAT'S NOT WORKING WELL AND
THAT'S WHERE I BELIEVE.
.
THE SUPERINTENDENT HAS OF. A
SOMEONE TO BOUNCE IDEAS OR JUST
BE REFLECTIVE.
WHERE IT'S MORE LIKE A COACH
CONSULTANT?
?
AND ACTING I AS A MORE OF A
REFLECTIVE RULE AND I HAVE TO
SHARE WITH YOU WHEN WE BEGAN
THIS PROCESS.
IT WAS DR COHN DOCTOR MOLINA
MYSELF FROM C. C. ALONG WITH.
DOCTOR WILLIAMS IN SITTING UP
TOGETHER ALL DAY.
LISTENING TO STAKEHOLDERS FROM
ALL DIFFERENT GROUPS OF VICTOR
VALLEY THAT'S HOW WE BEGAN OUR
PROCESSING GATHERING DATA SO
IT'S VERY DIFFERENT.
ORGANICALLY IN THAT WE'RE NOT
JUST LOOKING AT DASH FOR DATA OR
TO THOSE NUMBERS AND.
SURVEYS WERE ACTUALLY LISTENING
TO PEOPLE AND THEY HAVE A FACE
TO WHAT WE'RE DOING.
.
SO A BIG. LESSON TO LEARN FOR
ME.
WHY ARE FOLKS SO RECEPTIVE?
TO US.
WE DON'T HAVE ANY.
OF THE REGULATORY.
BUREAUCRATIC AND COMPLIANCE
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT OTHER
ENTITIES THAT.
AND AND I WOULD ARGUE THAT THE
MORE.
YOU DIMINISH.
THOSE REGULATORY BUREAUCRATIC
AND COMPLIANCE RESPONSIBILITIES
FROM OTHERS THE GREATER
RECEPTIVITY Y. LOG YET AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL.
IF I COULD ON PLAYING AND ALSO
AS YOU GUYS ARE LISTING TO. OUR
DIFFERENT ROLES THE COUNTY
OFFICE DOES PROVIDE.
PORT TO OUR DISTRICTS.
AND MORE FOR PREVENTION.
AND ALSO A AWAY THAT SUPPORTS
THEIR BUILDING OF CAPACITY.
SO FOR AS I STATED EARLIER EACH
GROUP OUR CHIEF ACADEMIC OFF
OFFICER MEET WITH ALL.
INSTRUCTIONAL LEADERS AN ENTIRE
COUNTY.
CARDS CBO AYE MEETS WITH ALL THE
CBO'S AND WE HAVE BEEN THE SAME
MESSAGE EMBEDDED CAPACITY.
EVEN AS THE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT I VISIT EVERY
SINGLE DISTRICT TWENTY THREE OF
THEM. I GO TO. I'M NO GOOD
DESTRUCTION LOOKS LIKE AND WE DO
TALK ABOUT IT. I THINK IT'S THE
APPROACH
I THINK THAT YOU HAVE YOU HAVE
TO HAVE SYSTEM SOMETIMES FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY IN EVEN MANDATES
BUT IT'S HOW YOU. DELIVER THAT
IS HOW YOU DO THAT HOW YOU SERVE
AND SUPPORT
BUT ALSO HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
SO I I WANT YOU TO CLEARLY
UNDERSTAND THE ROLE OF THE
COUNTY. AND THIS WHOLE DYNAMIC
THERE IS A DEFINITE WORLD THERE.
AND WE SEE IT FROM THE COUNTY
PERSPECTIVE. OP AS
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE WITH
THEM A TIERED SYSTEM.
THAT THERE'S A ROLE FOR US TO
MAKE SURE WE KEEP DISTRICTS FROM
GETTING INTO A PLACE WHERE THEY
HAVE TO GOING TO DIFFERENTIATE
ASSISTANCE.
BUT WE WERE ACTUALLY HAND IN
HAND WITH CC THERE SOME
DISTRICTS THAT WE HAVE DOUBLE
TEAMED. THERE SOME DISTRICT WE
SAID OKAY YOU TO TAKE AT THIS
POINT WE'RE GONNA TAKE A THAT
PART. BUT IT HAS TO BE CONTINUES
COMMUNICATION AND YOU HAVE TO DO
IT WOULD STUDENTS AT THE CENTER
OF IT ALL.
OKAY ARM BREAK YOU THANK YOU FOR
THAT AYE AYE ISA I LOVED IT
WE'RE ABOUT TO HEAR FROM TIME
FINANCE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL I LEAD TO THIS IN THE
LAST PANEL I WILL CERTAINLY ASK
ABOUT IT BUT OTHER THINGS YOU
WANT ME TO ASK THEM.
IN RELATION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND AND THIS.
THIS WHOLE CON CONVERSATION
ABOUT.
.
YOU KNOW I SEE BOTH CC  AND
THE COUNTY OFFICES ARE PROVIDING
IMPORTANT SUPPORT.
SYSTEMS.
ARE THERE THINGS THAT AND WE
OUGHT TO BE THINKING ABOUT THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE NEW BUDGET
AND ON THE POLICY SIDE DATE
RELATES TO THAT. BALANCES TO.
AS TO WHERE THE PROPER MIX OF
ROLES ARE BETWEEN THE CC
AND THE COUNTIES THE EXTENT TO
WHICH AN INDIVIDUAL ALLEGATION
BE ABLE TO DETERMINE.
WHERE THAT HONOR VENTURA COME
FROM OF THE ASSISTANCE?
BUSY YOUR UNDERSTANDING UNDER
THE.
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THAT THAT
PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE THAT
DISTRICTS WILL BE ABLE TO
REQUEST AS HE SEES SUPPORT
ASSISTANCE WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES.
TO PROVIDE THAT IF YOU WIND. ARE
THE COUNTIES IN THE C. C. E.
WORKING COLLABORATIVELY AND IN.
SITUATIONS WHERE THERE ARE
DISTRICTS IN NEED ASSISTANCE I'D
LOVE TO.
AND BETTER UNDERSTAND THIS
RELATIONSHIP IN THE IN THE ROLES
THAT YOU PLAY ON THE SUPPORTIVE
SIDE WITH THE DISTRICTS.
TYPICALLY. IF A DISTRICT REQUEST
OF US.
WE CHECK IN WITH THE COUNTY WE
TALK ABOUT THEIR CAPACITY OUR
CAPACITY AND IN MOST INSTANCES.
.
THE COUNTY THERE SAYS YEAH THAT
MAKES SENSE YOU GO AHEAD.
YOU WORK WITH THEM OR WE COME TO
SOME AGREEMENT AROUND YOU
PROVIDE THIS WILL PROVIDE THAT
IT HASN'T.
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE COUNTY SUIT
AT A MEETING WE.
HAD SAID.
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK
FOR EVERYBODY AND SO WE
SHOULDN'T NECESSARILY BE
TERRITORIAL ABOUT THIS.
LET'S GET THE YES WHEN IT COMES
TO SERVING DISTRICTS AND SO
THAT'S THAT'S THE APPROACH. THE
THE OTHER THING IS WE PRIDE
OURSELVES ON BEING FLEXIBLE. SO.
IF THERE'S A NEW ROLE OR A
DIFFERENT ROLE FOR US.
WE TAKE THOSE CHALLENGES.
WILL BE ANNOUNCING NEXT WEEK ON
A NEW PERSON COMING IN TO HEAD
UP.
WHAT WE'RE CALLING THE STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES COLLECTIVE THE
SW DE HOW DO YOU GET THE RIGHT
KIND OF HELP? TO THOSE ONE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED.
SO WE SEE OURSELVES AS.
ORIGINAL INTENT FLAT AGILE
NIMBLE WHEREVER WE NEED TO BE WE
CAN GET THERE UNSERVED
DISTRICTS.
OKAY DID YOU HAVE A COMMENT ON
THAT FROM THE PRETENDING
PERSPECTIVE JUST FROM THE COUNTY
PERSPECTIVE. EACH COUNTY IS
DIFFERENT BUT WITH THE
IDENTIFIED MONIES FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S RECOMMENDATION WE
WILL BE ABLE TO CONTINUE TO
SERVE AT A HIGH QUALITY.
AND I I LVE IS I CAN I CAN ONLY
SPEAK FROM MY EXPERIENCE THERE
WE HAVE INTENSELY BUILT. OVER
THE LAST DECADE
SO YOU YOU WON'T FIND A BETTER
TING.
AD AND WAIT WHAT TO DO.
AND AS I UNDERSTAND IT THERE.
WITH THE COUNTY OFFICES I MEAN I
WOULD ALSO ADVOCATE THAT. IN ANY
SORT OF SUPPORT GETS THROWN
THEIR WAY BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
OUR OUR COUNTY REALLY HELPS US A
LOT AND I THINK THAT.
.
YOU KNOW I I I TALK TO THEM
ABOUT WHAT KIND OF IDEAS THEY
HAVE IN TERMS OF THE TEAMS THEIR
BUILDING AND. AND WHAT THEY'VE
GOT GOING ON WHAT THEIR FUTURE
LOOKS LIKE AND HOW THEY WANT TO
SUPPORT US AND I'M. EXCITED AT
THE OPPORTUNITY SO THEY ARE
OFFERING MISS ACOSTA CHALLENGE
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND IT'S PART
OF WHY.
THE YOU KNOW THERE'S A QUITE A
DISPARITY IF YOU LOOK AT THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT'S SPENT BY
THE STATE ON K. TO TWELVE. AND
HOW MUCH ACTUALLY ENDS UP. IN
THE DISTRICT'S PER PUPIL. AND A
LOT OF IT'S BECAUSE OF THE
COUNTY INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
EXAMPLE.
I AM SO.
YOU KNOW WE WE WERE ABOUT TO SEE
PROVIDES ENORMOUSLY IMPORTANT
SERVICES IT'S ALSO.
PROP NINETY MINUTES ARE GOING
DIRECTLY DISTRICTS YOU KNOW THAT
THE OTHER THE
OTHER PART OF THIS DILEMMA.
NOT AN OVERLY DECISIONS TO MAKE.
GET IT COOK.
FROM THANK YOU PROCUREMENT.
THANK YOU SINGLE FURTHER COMMENT
FROM THE PANEL OR FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH VERY
INFORMATIVE.
AND VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
WORK YOU'RE DOING.
WHETHER WE GO TO ARE.
LAST BUT CERTAINLY NOT LEAST
PANEL. AND THAT WILL BE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR COUNTY
AND SELF OR REGIONAL.
STRUCTURES.
.
JESSICA HOLMES.
AMBER ALEXANDER DID THEIR FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ARE
HERE.
AND EDGAR COVERDELL AND SIR
CORTEZ FROM LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFF.
YOU MAY PROCEED WHEN READY I
DON'T WHO WANTS TO GO FIRST WHO
HAS GONE VERY SPLIT.
GO FORTH.
GOOD AFTERNOON JUST GO HOMES
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M HERE
WITH MY COLLEAGUE AMBER
ALEXANDER MCGEE TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS FOR.
ACCOUNTABILITY THE STATE SYSTEM
OF SUPPORT AND THEN ALSO HOW.
SOME OF THE PROPOSALS FOR
SPECIAL EDUCATION. ROLAND ALL OF
THAT.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE LCF ACCOUNTABILITY
IMPROVEMENTS SYSTEM.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THAT THAT'S
THE STRUCTURE ENGAGES ALL LOCAL
REGIONAL AND STATE EDUCATIONAL
ENTITIES AS WELL AS THEIR
STAKEHOLDERS.
AND A STRONG NETWORK OF
COLLABORATION IN ORDER TO STOP A
MINUTE HERE AND JUST KEY IN ON
THIS AND I THINK I THOUGHT WAS
REALLY IMPORTANT WHAT
SUPERINTENDENT BLAKE SAID ABOUT.
HOW YOU KNOW IN IN IN OTHER
COUNTIES HE'S HEARD
SUPERINTENDENT SAY THAT YOU KNOW
THEY DON'T THEY DON'T TALK TO
THEIR NEIGHBORS THEY DON'T
NECESSARILY HAVE AN ESTABLISHED
RELATIONSHIP TO DO THAT AND I
THINK THAT? ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT'S KEY TO THE STATE SYSTEM
OF SUPPORT ON IS ALLOWING PEOPLE
TO BUILD THOSE RELATIONSHIPS AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT RESOURCES ARE
OUT THERE.
SO THE STATE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
IS. REALLY FOCUSED ON EITHER
SIDE A NETWORK BY BEING A
NETWORK OF COLLABORATION
INNOVATION INFORMATION SHARING.
WITH A FOCUS ON IMPROVING
ACADEMIC OUTCOMES FOR ALL
STUDENTS.
AND REALLY CREATING A FOCUSED
ON CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT SET
ASIDE EIGHT GOALS.
SO IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES.
.
I'M SURE YOU'VE YOU'VE BUT WE'VE
KIND OF ARTY TOUCH ON THE FACT
THAT.
NEAR THE ADMINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING FIFTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
FOR IT LEAD COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION. AS WELL AS ELEVEN
POINT THREE MILLION ON GOING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA COLLABORATIVE AYE
WE TALK A BIT MORE ABOUT THAT IN
IN BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE.
BUT THE FOCUS OF THOSE FUNDS IS
REALLY ON BUILDING. A SUPPORT
NETWORK OF TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
SO I WANTED TO STOP RIGHT THERE
AND TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT AND
SOME OF THE THINGS YOU PART
ABOUT IT SENATOR ALLEN.
SPECIFICALLY AROUND THE ROLES
THAT THAT FOLKS ARE PLAYING IN
WHAT'S INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
SO IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WE
DO TALK ABOUT COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IS THE PRIMARY SUPPORT
PROVIDER FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
I WANT TO CLARIFY A FEW THINGS
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE I THINK
THEY'RE CEMENT MISINFORMATION
OUT THERE.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET DOES NOT
PROPOSE THAT COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION ARE THE ONLY SUPPORT
PROVIDERS AVAILABLE TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHETHER THEY'RE
IDENTIFIED FOR DIFFERENTIATED
ASSISTANCE OR NOT.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE LCF OF
FUNDS AND THAT THEY CAN USE TO
PROCURE ANY TYPE OF SUPPORT THAT
THEY WISH TO TO PROCURE.
WHAT THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PAN
PROPOSES IS THAT IF THE SCHOOLS
IDENTIFIED FOR DIFFERENTIATED
ASSISTANCE BUT THEY DO NEED TO
WORK WITH THEIR COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION?
BUT THEY DO NEED TO BRING IN
ANOTHER PARTNER BECAUSE IN IN
THE INSTANCE OF BEING IDENTIFIED
THEY'RE BASICALLY SHOWING THAT.
THERE REALLY STRUGGLING AT
LEAST ONCE A GROUP OF STUDENTS
AND EIGHT WE WANT TO SEE SOMEONE
ELSE COME IN AND PROVIDE SINCE
SOME SUPPORT.
WE ALSO REQUIRE THAT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IDENTIFIED AND HAS
BEEN IN NEED OF DIFFERENCE IS
SYSTEMS EXCEPT ASSISTANCE.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT.
WHATEVER THE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION SAYS AS WHAT THEY HAVE
TO DO THIS IS REALLY AN AT AN
OUTGROWTH OF THE WORK AROUND THE
LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLAN.
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
ALREADY WORKED CLOSELY WITH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ON THE ALL
CAPS.
THEY ARE THAT THE REVIEWERS OF
THE DISTRICT ALL CAPS AND THEY
ARE ON THE APPROVER IS THAT THE
DISTRICT ALCOTT.
SO IT VERY MUCH MAKES SENSE
THAT.
IF A SCHOOL DISTRICT ESPECIALLY
ONE THAT'S IN NEED OF
ASSISTANCE.
IS GOING TO TO BE WORKING ON
ADDRESSING SOME OF THEIR ISSUES
BUT THEY'RE GOING TO BE DOING IT
ALONGSIDE THEIR COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION.
THERE'S ALSO BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION AROUND THE CREATION
OF LEAD COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION WHICH IS ANOTHER PIECE
OF OUR GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL.
SO I WANT TO AND GO BACK TO
SOMETHING AS SENATOR ALAN THAT
YOU MENTIONED ABOUT.
THE ROLE OF THE C. C. E. VERSUS
THE ROLE OF COUNTIES.
WE THINK THAT THE COLLABORATIVE
AND COUNTIES BOTH PLAYING
IMPORTANT PART IN THE STATE
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
THE COUNTIES ARE.
I GUESS AT SOME OF OUR FOUR
PANELISTS MENTIONED THESE ARE
THE THE THE. THE PARTNERS OF OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THE NATURAL
PARTNERS TO OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY HAVE BEEN
THERE HEY UNDERSTAND THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND THEY WILL
CONTINUE TO BE THERE.
EVEN AFTER.
A SCHOOL DISTRICT MAYBE IMPROVE
THEIR SCORES OR EVEN IF THEY
CONTINUE TO DECLINE.
THEY ARE THE PARTNER THAT WILL
BE THERE FOR THE LONG TERM WE
TALKED ABOUT THE.
STING SYSTEM OR THE FEDERAL
SYSTEM OF SUPPORT WHERE I'M YOU
HAD MONEY FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME AND PEOPLE CAME IN. AND YOU
SAW IMPROVEMENTS ARE GAINES BUT
IT WAS ONLY AS LONG AS THE MONEY
LASTED.
pA SENSE OF CONTINUITY.
THAT EVEN ONCE.
WHOEVER'S PROVIDING SUPPORT
LEAVES THE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATIONAL BE THERE. THEY'LL BE
THERE IN THE GOOD TIMES TO
PROVIDE THAT TIER ONE LEVEL OF
SUPPORT THEY'LL BE THERE IN THE
BAD TIMES TO BE PARTNERS MATURE
TO MATURE THREE.
SO THAT'S THE CONTINUITY OF THE
SYSTEM.
WE ALSO AND IN OUR LANGUAGE
PROVIDE AVENUES.
FOR THE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION UMP THE DEAD THE
COLLABORATIVE AND THE DEPARTMENT
TO ASSIST SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
NEED OF EXTRAORDINARY SUPPORT.
THIS IS WHERE WE SEE THE COUNT
OF THE COLLABORATIVE REALLY
PLAYING AN IMPORTANT PART.
WE KNOW THAT SOME OF OUR COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
DEFINITELY NEED TO DO SOME WORK
ON BUILDING THEIR OWN CAPACITY
IN PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE.
WE THINK THAT THE COLLABORATIVE
CAN REALLY BE HELPFUL NOT WORK.
I'M WE ALSO SEE THAT THEY CAN BE
REALLY HELPFUL ON INCOMING IN
THAT TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT
MAYBE IN CRISIS OR.
ADDED AT RISK FOR BECOMING
IDENTIFIED FOR STATE
INTERVENTION WHICH IS OUR
TEACHER THREE LEVEL OF SUPPORT.
OR IN SITUATIONS WHERE THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IS NOT GOOD.
I'M FINALLY OUR PROPOSAL MIX
TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE
THE OLD API INDEX.
EH WHILE HOLDING IN PLACE.
.
THE TWENTY THIRTEEN CALCULATION
FOR PROGRAMS THAT ARE STILL IN
EXISTENCE THAT READ REQUIRE THAT
TO TO LET IT GO UP THE FUNDING
FOR THOSE PROGRAMS.
SO I'M HAPPY TO ENGAGE THEM IN
ANY KIND OF SCRATCHING LIKE TO
GET ON THIS TOPIC I MISS HER
NEVER TO MY PARTNER AND IN BROAD
CENTER TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOW. I'M WE ENVISION AS
THE YET THE MOVING AWAY FROM
THIS IDEA OF SPECIAL EDUCATION
AND GENERAL EDUCATION INTO AND
THE FOCUS ON THE WHOLE CHILD.
GOOD AFTERNOON NEVER ALEXANDER
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
FOLLOWING UP ON MY COLLEAGUES
PRESENTATION ON THE COUNTY
REGIONALES STRUCTURE GOING TO
FOCUS MY REMARKS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
INCORPORATE SPECIAL EDUCATION
LOCAL PLAN AREAS OR SOUTH BUYS
INTO THE STATE MIGHT SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT.
SO OPUS COORDINATE LOCAL SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES AND ALLOCATE
SPECIAL EDUCATION FUNDING TO
REGIONAL PROGRAMS AND DISTRICTS.
IN THE SPIRIT OF COORDINATION
ACROSS THE STATE THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROVIDES TEN MILLION AN
ON GOING PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDING. TO ESTABLISH SIX
TO TEN UPPLE LEADS WHO WILL
WORK WITH COUNTY OFFICES TO
IMPROVE STUDENT OUTCOMES AS PART
OF THE STATE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
RECOGNIZES THAT SELFLESS HAVE
EXPERTISE IN THE DELIVERY AND
MANAGEMENT OF SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES THAT COULD FURTHER
ENHANCE THE SUPPORT PROVIDED BY
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
IN THE ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES
THAT BRINGING SUPPERS INTO THE
STATE SYSTEM OF SUPPORT IS
CRITICAL. GIVEN THAT NEARLY
THREE QUARTERS OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IDENTIFIED FOR
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE NEED
TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES.
THE NEED TO INTEGRATE SPECIAL
EDUCATION WITH GENERAL EDUCATION
IS A THEME THAT HAS BEEN
HIGHLIGHTED TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
MOST RECENTLY WITH REPORTS BY
BOTH THE PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE
OF CALIFORNIA IN THE STATE WIDE
SPECIAL EDUCATION TASK FORCE.
BOTH CALLING FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A UNIFIED
SYSTEM WHERE GENERAL IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION ARE PART OF A SEAMLESS
SYSTEM OF STUDENT SUPPORT.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO BRING
FOCUS INTO THE STATE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT THROUGH THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF A REGIONALES
STRUCTURE. FURTHERS HIS EFFORTS
TO INTEGRATE SPECIAL EDUCATION
AND GENERAL EDUCATION INTO ONE
COHESIVE ASSIST.
ONE COHESIVE SYSTEM AND WITH
THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
A GOOD AFTERNOON SARAH CORTEZ AT
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
AND I WILL BE SPEAKING FROM A
HAND OUT THAT WAS DISTRIBUTED
EARLIER. I'M SO WHERE WE WERE
ASSN A DISK TO DISCUSS OUR
ASSOCIATED RECOMMENDATIONS ON
THE GOVERNOR'S REGIONAL THE
PROPOSALS I'M SO PAGE ONE.
ACTUALLY PRODUCE SHOWS A
SUMMARY OF THESE PROPOSALS I'M
SO WHAT YOU HEARD FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION SO THAT YOU
PROPOSALS ALL.
LIMIT MY COMMENTS TO YOU ARE
THE READ THE COUNTY OFFICE
REGIONALLY PUT PROPOSAL WHICH IS
FOUR MILLION.
WHICH IS A FOUR MILLION ONGOING
AUGMENTATION AND ALSO THE SELF
Y. REGIONALLY PROPOSAL WHICH IS
THE TEN MILLION DOLLAR
AUGMENTATION.
SO MOVING ALONG TO PAGE TWO OF
THE HANDOUT DESCRIBES OUR
ASSESSMENTS OF THESE PROPOSALS
SO OUR CONCERN. WITH THE
REGIONALLY PROPOSAL IS THAT A P.
IT APPEARS DUPLICATIVE TO BOOK
NEWLY ESTABLISHED ROLES WITHIN
THE ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM AN
ALREADY EXISTING REGIONALES
STRUCTURE. SO FOR EXAMPLE ELEVEN
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
ALREADY RECEIVE FUNDING SERVICE
REGIONAL MEANS.
THERE'S ALSO A LACK OF CLARITY
SURROUNDING THE ROLE OF THE
REGIONAL LEAD SO FOR EXAMPLE. A
COUNTY OFFICE REGIONAL LEAVES
ARE INTENDED TO BUILD THE
CAPACITY COUNTYOFFICE OF
EDUCATION BUT ALSO PART OF THEIR
ROLE IS TO SUPPORT DISTRICTS
DIRECTLY. OMITS UNCLEAR AT WHAT
POINT ON A REGIONAL LEGAL
SUPPORT DISTRICTS AND HOW
DECISIONS TO SUPPORT DISTRICTS
WILL BE MADE.
THIS LACK OF CLARITY ALSO RAISES
CONCERNS FOR THE CELLPHONE ROLES
DESPITE THE PROPOSAL'S INTENDING
TO.
TO ADD SELF WAS TO THE
CONVERSATION OF IMPROVING
DISTRICTS THE LACK OF CLARISSE
CLARITY SURROUNDING THE ROLE
COULD RESULT IN COUNTIES
DEFERRING DISTRICT SUPPORT TO
CELEBUZZ AND AND OUR CONCERN IS
THIS WOULD DISCONNECT SPECIAL
EDUCATION PERFORMANCE ISSUES.
FROM OTHER STUDENT PERFORMANCE
ISSUES.
ON ANOTHER NOTE CELL PHONES ARE
EXPERTS PROVIDING SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES UP BUT THE
ISSUES THE DASHBOARD HIGHLIGHTS
OUR GENERAL EDUCATION ISSUES
SUCH AS TEST SCORES AND
SUSPENSION RATES. A WE WOULD
CONSIDER THAT THE PERFORMANCE
ISSUES THAT THE DASHBOARD
HIGHLIGHTS OUR GENERAL EDUCATION
ISSUES THAT ARE DICTATED BY THE
SAME POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
THAT APPLY TO US ALL STUDENT
POPULATIONS. SO FOR EXAMPLE ON
PERFORMANCE FOR STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES IS LARGELY
DETERMINED BY GENERAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS WHO HA OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES IN THE CLASSROOM.
ALL THIS TO SAY IT'S UNCLEAR TO
US WHY WE NEED A SEPARATE ENTITY
INTERVENING FOR ISSUE SPECIFIC
TO STUDENTS WITH THE BEST WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEN RELY ON A
DIFFERENT SOURCE OF EXPERTISE
FOR THOSE SAME ISSUES WHEN THEY
OCCUR WITH OTHER STUDENT
POPULATIONS.
SO PAGE THREE WE DISCUSS OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS.
SO GIVEN OUR CONCERNS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WE RECOMMEND
SHE REJECTING BOTH THE REGIONAL
BOTH OF THE REGIONALLY
PROPOSALS.
IN BECAUSE CREATING OF THE SITE
PRE CREATING THESE ROLES ON
LEADS TO UNNECESSARY DUPLICATION
AND BUT ALSO SELF WAS THE SUPPLE
ROLE COULD SILO SUPPORT INSTEAD
OF FOSTERING CONVERSATION THAT'S
THE ADMINISTRATION INTENDS.
SO WE PROPOSE AN ALTERNATIVE TO
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THAT WE
THINK MAINTAIN THE LEGISLATIVE
INTENT OF LC A FIVE UP WITHOUT
CREATING ADDITIONAL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT. WE RECOMMEND USING
THE COLLABORATIVE FOR
EDUCATIONAL EXCELLENCE WHICH IS
THE NEW ENTITY THAT WAS FORMED
GENERALLY TO ASSIST DISTRICTS.
BUT USING IT AS AN ENTITY THAT
OPERATES SIMILAR EFFECT MATT. ON
WHICH IS THE STATE'S FISCAL
ACCOUNTABILITY ENTITY SO WE
RECOGNIZE THIS WOULD BE A CHANGE
FROM CURRENT LAW AND WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES. BUT
PERFECT ABOUT ONCE A DISTRICT
HAS DEMONSTRATED THAT THE NEEDS
FISCAL ASSISTANCE DEVELOPED A
TEAM OF EXPERTS.
THAT CAN SUPPORT THE DISTRICT
IN SOME VERY SPECIFIC AREAS. WE
THINK WE COULD BUILD OFF THAT
THE SUCCESS THAT WE'VE SEEN WITH
THICK MAT OF SUPPORTING
DISTRICTS AND MODEL THE
COLLABORATIVE TO OPERATE
SIMILARLY.
SO THE FIRST STEP IN ALTERNATIVE
IS THAT THE IDENTIFIED DISTRICT
WOULD WORK WITH COUNTY OFFICE OF
WITH COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
TO UNCOVER THEIR ROOT CAUSES IN
THE PERFORMANCE ISSUE WERE
CAUGHT ROOT CAUSES FOR THEIR
PERFORMANCE ISSUES. AND THIS IS
SIMILAR TO WHAT THEY HAVE
DESCRIBED TODAY AS WHAT THEY'RE
CURRENTLY DOING. I'M SO ONCE THE
COUNTY COMPLETED THIS RECALLS
ANALYSIS THE NEXT STEP WOULD BE
THAT THE DISTRICT WOULD THEN
WORK WITH THE COLLABORATIVE. TO
IDENTIFY AN EXPERT OR TEAM OF
EXPERTS THAT THE DISTRICT COULD
WORK WITH THAT WOULD ADDRESS THE
ROOT CAUSES FOR PERFORMANCE
ISSUES.
THE EXPERTS I'M IDENTIFIED HERE
COULD BE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION OTHER PROVIDERS OF
EDUCATION SERVICES AND EDUCATION
CONSULTANT SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THE IDEA IS A COLLABORATIVE
WOULD HAVE EXPERTS UNDER
CONTRACT SO THAT WE NEEDED
EXPERTS WOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
DISTRICTS THAT NEED SUPPORT.
THE RECOMMENDED SYSTEM WOULD
PROVIDE DISTRICTS WITH GREATER
CHOICE IN SELECTING EXPERTS ARE
NOT REQUIRED DISTRICTS COULD
WORK WITH THE COLLABORATIVE TO
CHOOSE THE CONTRACTED EXPERTS
I'M BEST SUITED TO HELP ADDRESS
THEIR KEY PERFORMANCE ISSUES.
AND WE THINK DISTRICTS HAVE A
STRONG INCENTIVE TO CHOOSE OUR
PER SUPPORT PROVIDERS WISELY.
UNDER STATE LAW IF DISTRICTS
FACE REPERCUSSIONS IF THEY FAIL
TO IMPROVE ON THE GET INTO
INTENSIVE INTERVENTION AFTER
SEVERAL YEARS OF POOR DISTRICT
PERFORMANCE. ONCE THEY GET INTO
IT INTENSIVE INTERVENTION THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION CAN REQUIRE BUDGET
AND HEALTHCARE PROVISIONS ON AS
WELL AS STAN RESCIND AB DISTRICT
BOARD DECISIONS.
I'M WITH ALL THE SAID REPRESENT
THIS OPTION TO DISPLAY THAT
THERE'S MORE THAN ONE MODEL FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER TO
ACHIEVE THE DESIRED OUTCOME OF
SUPPORTING DISTRICTS.
AND THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS
BUT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
.
DO WE HAVE ONE MORE SPEAKER.
NO OKAY YOU ARE GREAT O. THAT
ARE QUESTIONS FROM THE PANEL.
LOOK AT.
FRESNO APPRECIATIVE RUNS.
THOUGHTFUL.
PRESENTATIONS I'M.
LET ME JUST START BY ASKING THE
FOLKS FROM THE PART OF FINANCE
DO YOU DO YOU HAVE.
I'M SURE YOU DO HAVE THOUGHTS.
ASSOCIATE ALEJO'S
RECOMMENDATIONS WHAT WHAT ARE
YOUR REACTIONS TO THEIR
PROPOSALS SURE YEAH. SO I THINK
ON.
THE UTILIZING THAT THE
COLLABORATIVE TO IDENTIFY.
THAT EXPERTS
TO COME IN AND PROVIDE SUPPORT
AND THERE'S A COUPLE OF ISSUES
WE HAVE WITH THAT.
ONE THE EL CAP IS RELIEVED THE
CENTERPIECE OF OUR
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM IT'S WHERE
I'M COMMUNITIES AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS COME TOGETHER AND
DISCUSS.
DASHBOARD RESULTS AND WHAT THEY
WANT TO DO WHAT THEIR PRIORITIES
ARE WHAT THEY WANTED YOU TO
ADDRESS.
I'M ANY SHORTCOMINGS THEY HAVE.
AND. THE COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
PARTNER IN ALL OF THAT. ON
BECAUSE THEY ARE THE ONES WHO
ARE PROVING THE PLANS.
AND WE ARE CONCERNED THAT.
S.. MAKING THE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION ROLE I'M SIMPLY TO
INVOLVE THEMSELVES IN THE
RECALLS ANALYSIS REALLY DIVORCES
THEM FROM THE PROCESS OF
IDENTIFYING SOLUTIONS.
AND THAT'S A REALLY KEY
COMPONENT OF THE EL CAP AND WHAT
THE COUNTY HAS TO APPROVE SO WE
THINK THAT THAT'S AN ISSUE.
WE ALSO ARE CONCERNED THAT
BRINGING IN THE SHORT TERM PANEL
OF EXPERTS ON DOESN'T REALLY GET
THAT LONG TERM CHANGE ISSUE THAT
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT. AND SO
WE HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH THAT.
FINALLY I THINK.
BUT YOU KNOW WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT RICK CAUSE ANALYSIS AND
IDENTIFYING I'M A SOLUTION I
THINK IT'S WE THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT THAT AS. WE'RE LOOKING
AT THE CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT
MODEL THAT WE'RE NOT.
WE'RE NOT BRINGING IN DIFFERENT
ENTITIES FOR THOSE TWO DIFFERENT
PARTS THOSE TWO THINGS ARE NOT
NECESSARILY. SEPARATE PIECES
BAD.
THE TEAM SHOULD BE WORKING ON
IDENTIFYING THE ROOT CAUSES AS
WELL AS. WORKING ON FACILITATING
ON A CREATION OF THE PROPOSED
SOLUTIONS AS ONE PROCESS
SO THOSE ARE THREE OF THE THE
BIG ISSUES.
SO WHAT ENDS UP HAPPENING LIKE
WITH THAT BUDGET NEGOTIATION
OVER THIS DID DO YOU GUYS END OF
SAY THE OTHERS IT IS YOU GET
NEGOTIATED OUT. AMONGST.
.
SENATORS WITH.
DIRECTLY WITH YOU ARE HAPPY JUST
STRUCTURALLY HOW. THIS SORT OF.
DIFFERENCE THE VISIONS AS TO HOW
WE OUGHTA.
STRUCTURE THAT THE RECENTLY
PROPOSAL.
HOW THAT PLAY OUT NOW OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE MONTHS?
AB WILL CERTAINLY AND WE STILL
HAVE SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS ON ON
THIS TOPIC.
YET TO COME.
OBVIOUSLY WE PROPOSE WE PRESENT
OUR PROPOSAL DELEO PRESENT
THERE'S AND THE LEGISLATURE CAN
CHOOSE TO.
PROPOSED ITS OWN LANGUAGE M.
AND HOW IT THINKS THE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT SHOULD LOOK.
BUT CERTAINLY YOUR PREROGATIVE
AND AND YOU KNOW ONE THAT WE'RE
HAPPY TO HAVE AS AN
ADMINISTRATION WERE HAPPY TO
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH
LEGISLATURE'S THE LA JOH THAN IN
THE.
BUDGET LANGUAGE NEGOTIATIONS ARE
SAT DOWN BY PRO TEM SPEAKER
STAFF.
I WILL HAVE TO DEFER TO PEOPLE
WHO MAKE A LOT MORE MONEY THAN I
DO ON THAT.
IF YOU GUYS NOW. MAPS I WOULD
SAID THAT THE WAY WE WE EXPECT
AT THE PALACE THROUGH THE
SUBCOMMITTEE PROCESS BOTH BOTH
HOUSES HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPRESS THEIR CONCERNS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL. AND
AND INCLUDE ANY CHANGES THEM IN
AND THAT BUDGET RIGHT THEN THEM
THROUGH THAT THERE WILL BE. THAT
THIS ISSUE WOULD BE DISCUSSED
THE CONFERENCE COMMITTEE AND
THAT WOULD CREATE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR MORE
NEGOTIATIONS WE ARE AVAILABLE.
TO TO THE LEGISLATURE AS
NEITHER OF IN ANY SITUATION SO
IF THERE ARE I'M CASES WHERE
WHERE YOU WOULD LIKE OUR.
SUPPORT RAVI FIAT ALWAYS
AVAILABLE IT'S REALLY UP TO AND
THE LEGISLATURE TO DECIDE HOW
MUCH. HOW MUCH YOU WANT IT TO BE
INVOLVED IN THOSE AND
NEGOTIATION?
SO ITS ARE BUDGET COMMITTEE
LEADERSHIP AND CONFERENCE
COMMITTEE STAFF THAT AND DECIDE
THE EXTENT TO WHICH THEY WANNA.
BY ANDY YOUR ARGUMENTS AND THEN
ENGAGE YOU TO HELP WITH THE
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE.
MARROW WITH ANYTHING I WOULD
EXPECT THAT THAT THE WAVE THIS
TURNS AWAY. IN TERMS OF
THE SPECIFIC OPINION THAT
MEMBERS HAVEN'T AND JIM I'M SURE
THAT THERE ARE.
MEMBERS WERE NOT PART OF.
OUT BUDGET COMMITTEES WHO HAVE.
STRONG PREFERENCES FOR ALL THAT
WOULD PLAY OUT COMMITTING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WILL HAPPEN IT
ITEM.
AND A VARIETY OF PLACES HOW DO
YOU WHAT'S THE PURPOSE THE
PROCEDURE BY WHICH YOU END UP
DEVELOPING THESE CRITICS IS ARE
YOU GET WITH TEAM OF STAFF TO A
FAMILIAR TO. EXAMINE AND ANALYZE
THE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND.
BASED ON YOUR EXPERTISE IN YOUR
READING AND KNOWLEDGE SHE'LL.
COME UP HERE STATUTES
AND SO THIS IS REALLY THE FOR
THE FIRST TIME IT'S COME UP TO
YOU BUT WE'VE BEEN WONDERING IF
ISSUE AND AND THINKING
INTERNALLY ABOUT WHAT WE'VE.
WILL THINK OF US OR SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT TO LOOK LIKE IT'S OF AND
THAT'S INFORMED.
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE
PROVIDED TO YOU OKAY.
TOLD IN RELATED I'M SURE YOU'VE
DONE SOMETHING SIMILAR FOR BOTH
THE GOVERNOR'S.
THREE COLLEGE
FINDING.
REJECT AIR PLUS THE.
THE ONLINE COLLEGE AND I'D LOVE
TO GET THE EARLIER REPORTS ON
THOSE TWO.
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THOSE I'M SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOUR
CLARIFICATION ON THE SEC
ACADEMY.
MANDATE QUESTION I THAT THAT
THAT'S HELPFUL AND.
AT SOME POINT IN BOTH OF US ARE
ENGAGING IN A. BITING A REALLY
INNOCENT CONVERSATION ABOUT THE
WAY WE REALLY LOOK AT SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING IN GENERAL.
TIME IS NOT ENTIRELY.
THIS I IT IT'S A LITTLE
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT YOU PUT YOUR
DEBATING HERE ABOUT.
NO THE SELF ORIGINALLY THE SILOS
AND THE LIKE BUT AND BUT BUT BUT
REALLY AND LOOKING AT THE CENTER
WHICH WE GOTTA. RETHINK THAT
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT.
I'D DECISION TO JUST GIVES HIM
OUT OF MONEY DALY IS BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF KIDS THEY HAVE
BEEN AND HOW.
THAT'S I REALLY WORKING WELL FOR
DISTRICTS ON THE GROUND SO THAT
TO ENGAGE OF YOUNG COMPETITION.
EXCEPT THAT YOU.
THANK YOU. AND SEE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS FOR US PANEL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
A VERY WELL DONE.
WITH THAT.
I BELIEVE THIS SPRING SO HOW
COME.
PUBLIC COMENT SORRY.
WE WILL NOW TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU COME ON UP JUST STATE YOUR
NAME. AFFILIATION IF YOU HAVE
ANY THOUGHTS PLEASE KEEP IT TO
THIRTY SECONDS.
BECAUSE ONLY BECAUSE WILL NOT
ONLY BECAUSE BUT BECAUSE WE HAVE
ANOTHER HEARING COMING IN.
AT FOUR O'CLOCK.
YEAHYEAH GOOD AFTERNOON I
CHAIRS A WHISKEY AND WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES.
AS YOU KNOW WE WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE COALITION OF
OTHER ADVOCACY GROUPS AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
WHO CALL THEMSELVES THE EQUITY
COALITION A WE REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT YOU'VE TAKEN THE TIME TO
LEARN ABOUT THE SYSTEM OF
SUPPORT WE KNOW THERE'S MUCH
MORE TO LEARN?
WHAT YOU DIDN'T HEAR THOUGH IS
THE ROLE OF COMMUNITY ON WHICH
ARE REALLY AN IMPORTANT PLAYER?
IN LOCAL CONTROL YOU HEARD A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT RELATIONSHIPS
AND HOW IMPORTANT THEY ARE. BUT
LCF F. GAVE FLEXIBILITY OUGHT TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN EXCHANGE FOR ENGAGEMENT
INFORMED BY TRANSPARENCY.
THE MECHANISMS THAT SUPPORT ALL
THAT. ARE REALLY NEED TO BE
PULLED APART AND RESOURCES THAT
INTENTIONALLY HELP. DISTRICTS
DEVELOP CAPACITY TO LEARN HOW TO
ENGAGE ARE REALLY CRITICAL AND
WILL BE TALKING ABOUT THAT IN
FUTURE LEGISLATION AS WELL AS IN
BUDGET.
SO I HOPE YOU WILL EXPLORE THAT
FURTHER THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ATTORNEY CIVIL FROM SIDE ATTACK
AND I JUST WANT TO QUICKLY AYE
AYE COMING COMPLAIN ABOUT
ALTERNATIVE ACCOUNTABILITY ALL
THE TIME AND I JUST WANT TO COME
UP AND SAY. THAT I APPRECIATE
THE FOCUS OF CHARACTER CARE
CASTING HIS TEAMMATE CD DAVID
SAPPING HIS TEAMMATES STATE
BOARD. AND DOCTOR CARL COHN WHO
MET WITH US EARLY ON TO TALK
ABOUT.
WHAT KIND OF SERVICES AND THAT
COULD BE PROVIDED TO SCHOOLS
LIKE OURS TO SEE SEE?
AND WE THANK YOU AND YOUR
ONGOING INTEREST IN DEVELOPING A
RELEVANT ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM
THIS IS WE'VE FOR MAKING GREAT
PROGRESS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND.
MEMBERS OF THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE ON THE DOOR LIKE THAT
WHICH WOULD RENOWNED WHICH ONE
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT THE
DIRECTION THE STATE IS GOING
TERMS AS THE. ASSISTANT SPORTS
AND THINGS IMPROVING EFFORTS WE
REALLY DO THINK THAT THE
DISTRICT HAS THE RIGHT UNIT OF
CHANGE AND AS WE EXPLORE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY. OF. HOW WE
STRUCTURE THE ACCOUNTABILITY
PROCESS AND WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE AND THE? GENERAL
ASSEMBLY TO REALLY THINK ABOUT
ALLOCATING AN APPROPRIATE
FUNDING IN THE FORMER TITLE ONE
DOLLAR. IN THE FORMER FUNDING
FOR TITLE ONE SCHOOL.
SCHOOL'S. OUT WHEELS ONE EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSALS IN TERMS OF THE
FUNDING FOR THE COUNTY OFFICES
OF EDUCATION THE CCD AND THE
SUPPER AND REALLY FINDING WAYS
TO INTEGRATE THOSE SYSTEMS. AND
WE DO WANT TO HIGHLIGHT JUST TO
OPPORTUNITIES ONE IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHERE.
CREATING A CLIP OF PROVIDING
CLARITY OF ON THE USE OF OR
THOSE THEIR SUPPORT WERE OFFERED
AND LEVEL ONE SUPPORTS FOR ALL
DISTRICTS. TO REALLY MAKE SURE
WE TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
CONFERENCE SYSTEM SUPPORT FOR
DISTRICTS
AND THE SECOND IS THAT WE DO
WANT US EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR THE.
OUR LEAD COE STRUCTURE THAT WAS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR TO
BUDGET POTENTIAL FOR LEADERSHIP
IN.
TO SUPPORT THIS.
GOOD AFTERNOON EARLY ANGELA REED
ON BEHALF OF THE SMALL SCHOOL
DISASSOCIATION BUTTE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION WHEN I THANK
YOU FOR THIS HEARING ANY
OPPORTUNITY HERE ONE THANK YOU
FOR INVITING SMALL THREE PART OF
THIS. MY GOOD COLLEAGUE ADAM LIZ
GANG MENTIONED COMMUNITY AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE HAVE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL THE WORK AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL FOLKS WORKING
TOGETHER.
IT IS ME ARE MAKING THINGS
HAPPEN THAT HAVING AN EFFECT AND
AS IF YOU WERE TO BE AT ONE OF
THESE MEETINGS BUTTE COUNTY YOU
WOULD SEE IT'S NOT A COMBINED
OUTSIDE I LOVE IT'S A FAMILY.
DISCUSSION WHERE EVERY HOLDS IN
THE COMMUNITY IS THERE'S.
THE STUDENTS THEIR STAY THERE OR
THEY GO WHEN THEY COME BACK IT'S
AN INVESTMENT IN THEIR COMMUNITY
AND I THINK THE BURKE COUNTY
OFFICE IN THE DISTRICTS DO
TOGETHER. IS REALLY SHOWING THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY SO THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS STEVE
HENDERSON REPRESENTING THE
COUNTY SOUP SINCE THE ASIAN. I
JUST WANT TO COME UP AND SAY WE
THANK YOU FOR.
THE MENTION OF THE WORK IS
SUCCESS IS DOING WITH THE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION. IN ORDER TO
ESTABLISH A FOUNDATION TO HELP
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT FIND
THEMSELVES AND DIFFERENTIATED
ASSISTANCE.
WE SUPPORT THE BUDGET
APPROPRIATION IN THE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET TO PROVIDE
MORE MONEY FOR COUNTY OFFICES TO
HELP US BUILD CAPACITY AND
CONTINUE TO HELP THOSE
DISTRICTS.
VETERAN DIFFERENTIATED CITIZENS
BUT ALSO PROVIDE THEM WITH THE
TOOLS AS A PREVENTATIVE MEASURE
TO PREVENT OTHER DISTRICTS FROM
GETTING INTO DIFFERENTIATED
ASSIST.
THANK.
THANK YOU I SEE NO FURTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT.
I WILL DURING THIS.
HEARING AND THANK YOU AGAIN TO
ALL OUR PARTICIPANTS ENOUGH FOR
ALL OF YOUR PRESENCE HERE TODAY
THANK YOU